hey what's going on it's bill byrne it's
time for the thursday afternoon just
before friday monday morning podcast and
i'm just checking in on you
i'm just checking to see how your week's
going you know you know out there i know
there's a lot of difficulties a very
difficult time it's a time where a lot
of people don't feel safe
there's there's there's a lot of
hysteria there's a lot of craziness
there's a pile of people losing their
[ __ ] about stuff that doesn't [ __ ]
matter in the overall picture who gives
a [ __ ] about this that and the other
thing when we might not even be able to
live on the planet if we keep going the
way we're going right
happy thursday everybody
how's it going oh my god oh freckles
you know
oh pasty thighs just [ __ ] came up for
air my god i went um when you when we
last checked in with bill
from [ __ ] i don't know friday or
saturday of last week
until last night at like 9 30 i did
nothing but work on [ __ ] writing this
script and getting it ready for people
to look at
and uh i got to tell you something the
fact
that actors get all these [ __ ] awards
and attention and then you don't know
who the writers are i swear it was one
of the most ridiculous things
we were cranking this thing we finally
got the thing done my writing part is
going like ah man you know i can't wait
to do like the sandler thing and do one
of these every couple of years i'm like
dude i don't think i ever want to do one
of these again
[Music]
my brain was fried but now i'm psyched
because now i'm on the other side of it
i think it's a really good script who
knows you know you write these things
you bring them out you hope someone's
gonna [ __ ] buy it and if they don't
you're like hey well you know
i guess i'll try it a different way you
know and that's what life is
you get up there you take a swing of the
bat
you see if you can make some contact put
it in play maybe every once in a while
you hit a [ __ ] home run you know but
most of the times you strike out you go
back to the dugout you don't get to ride
in the laundry cart right that's what it
is
all right but try telling that to these
broads
oh my god if i have one more woman tell
me how [ __ ] easy my life is you know
i started dropping weight you know i was
down the comedy club and i mentioned
that to someone
she goes well yeah you know you're a guy
i mean you guys just like think of
losing weight you drop weight oh yeah
that's exactly how it is it's exactly
how it is that's why you never see a
[ __ ] fat guy on my 600 pound life
that's like a thing like with women they
go you you just think about losing
weight and you lose weight it's like no
no
that's not how it works
i've been trying to drop this weight for
a whole [ __ ] year
i've been thinking about it for a whole
[ __ ] year thinking about it
and make it happen
right
so
i don't know what the hell it did it
just like it's just one of those things
you just have to sit there and listen to
i told you that i was at the doctor's
right and she was i had one of those
[ __ ] old man spots developing on my
head and like i can't i can't have this
so she's lasering the thing off and i
just say yeah you know she goes want me
to numb you up
and i said uh you know well how bad does
it hurt she goes you know it's like
somebody snapping an elastic on your
head i was like
all right well let's see how it goes
right she stole it it wasn't even that
bad then she said to me she goes you
know i gotta admit she goes
you have like a you have like a high
level of threshold for pain
you know you're like a woman
she [ __ ] said that to me i was just
like jesus christ i was trying to think
i know i told this story before but i
know you guys don't listen every week i
was just trying to think
like
the opposite of that like if i said if i
was the doctor
and i had a woman in the chair and i
said something like that
like wow you're like really smart you
know you're like a man
you have a high threshold of pain like a
man like if i said something like that
practice over done
and then that nebby on that [ __ ]
e-show
something what happened so anyway um
yeah i've been dropping weight
i'm just trying to go two pounds a week
been eating great
i'm kind of i'm off like sugar and salt
now
and um last night you know we took a
break because our brain was so fried
and i put on the world series which uh
i'm getting such a kick out of it that i
guess
people in sports were saying that
atlanta braves versus the houston astros
was a nightmare
for major league baseball as far as
ratings goes
and what are they going to do they're
going to turn around and blame the
cities
and blame the teams rather than blame
themselves
that because of pile on teams and money
certain teams
were able to be you know considered more
interesting than other cities because i
know when i watch the super bowl it
doesn't matter who the [ __ ] playing
i know the arizona cardinals formerly
the saint louis cardinals formerly the
chicago cardinals have sucked dick my
entire [ __ ] life except for one year
when they had kurt warner and they
played one of the greatest super bowls
of all time unfortunately losing i
believe to the was it the packers or was
it the steelers i can't remember it was
an amazing super bowl right
they've absolutely sucked
and all of a sudden they're great they
got kyla murray
they got chandler jones they got j.j
watts i love them
i can watch them all day they're
exciting
i don't care that they're in arizona
you know stop blaming the cities you're
not running your [ __ ] league right
sorry i'm not like 100 flipping out
about this it's just 6 30 in the [ __ ]
morning trying to knock this out before
i get the kids ready
for their days here um
yeah what kind of [ __ ] world do you
trash in atlanta atlanta has some of the
most beautiful women i've ever seen in
my life
you know it's got great food
other than the traffic it's [ __ ]
amazing
in houston
you know it's a it's an american city
you shouldn't be trashing it
i'm kidding joel olst okay houston has
joel olsteen
houston won back to back fattest cities
in america which is a dynasty because
it's so hard it's really hard to do that
i think it's like political right let me
just see when was their dynasty i want
to say it was in the 2000s
because see the cowboys had a dynasty in
the 90s as did the yankees and then
houston had a dynasty
with fat people let's see here
fattest city
in america
year by year all right
let's see what we got here
okay fattest cities in america
2021 fattest city in america
fatty cities they won't go year by year
well let's see who's got it this year
let's see who's taking the title
okay according to this thing mcallen
texas
i've never even heard of that place
memphis tennessee
baton rouge louisiana i did some acting
work there man it's hard to buy anything
that isn't fried that's a tough city to
be in
uh little rock arkansas
these are all the non-vaccine cities
jesus christ people
i hope you're wearing mess shreveport
louisiana birmingham alabama jackson
mississippi
mobile alabama
alabama alabama lafayette louisiana
louisiana coming in strong baton rouge
shreveport lafayette
knoxville tennessee
chattanooga tennessee tulsa oklahoma
augusta georgia
greenville south carolina fayetteville
arkansas
myrtle beach south carolina oh you hate
to see it a bunch of fatties walking
around bathing suits
san antonio texas wichita kansas new
orleans
louisiana
nashville tennessee so you got to say
louisiana's the fattest [ __ ] state
out there
tennessee all their big cities memphis
chattanooga nashville
mcallen also has the highest share of
physically inactive adults
36.90 percent
well how about hats off that they were
active enough to take that survey
uh which is 2.2 times higher than provo
orem utah the metro area with the lowest
at 16.5 16 and a half percent of the
people are active
el paso texas has the highest share of
diabetic adults oh god you don't want
that
which is 2.3 times higher
than in denver
the metro area with the the lowest oh
yeah they're out there [ __ ]
white water raft in there
um
so anyway i got to watch a little bit of
the uh
atlanta houston game and the first
atlanta won the first game six to two
houston [ __ ] won uh seven to two
and i'm calling them the astros because
as a patriots fan
to watch them do what they did and it's
i haven't even heard it brought up yet
this isn't them trying to redeem the
fact that they got busted with their
pants down cheating their [ __ ] asses
off banging on that trash can nothing i
was watching the game last night
right and el tube hits a [ __ ] home
run
the announcer goes
you know that's his 22nd home run
his 22nd home run in post-season play
and he's like you know 14 of those that
were at home oh yeah when they had the
[ __ ] trash can and he knew a changeup
was coming
nothing absolutely [ __ ]
nothing
and i got it as a pats fan
to still listen people talk to me about
the flake gate which went to court it
was laughed that wasn't even left out of
court the guy got [ __ ] upset about it
saying stop wasting my time
[ __ ] unbelievable we have a drug
addict but the dead mistress hires a
scientist who isn't what isn't one to
come up with some boss hog dukes of
hazard [ __ ] and it sticks
it [ __ ] sticks these [ __ ] go
to home depot buy some trash cans they
get [ __ ] busted doing it
was it [ __ ] two years later three
three [ __ ] four years later
ah it's amazing this guy's been
unbelievably successful
i told you i saw the same thing with
[ __ ] a-rod when he played with the
yankees guy gets busted doing steroids
you know and everybody's ah [ __ ] this
guy guys terrible baseball blah blah
blah all this [ __ ] [ __ ] then the guy
hits his 600th home run same [ __ ]
newspapers where do we put him
historically
the greatest shortstop third baseman of
all [ __ ] time a couple of years later
i don't know unreal but i can tell you
this it's a [ __ ] great series
it's predicting that's going to go six
to seven games and i've always said this
thing because i i look at houston like
okay they cheated but then again my red
sox and the new york yankees had 200
million dollar roided up free agent
teams
okay and we want a bunch of them doing
that so i'm not going to [ __ ] sit
there and say that however
you know i might act like we're all
[ __ ] innocent here but i mean i i'm
just beside myself
that you can come back and then that is
not the story
hey can the houston astros win a legit
one
without going down to the hardware store
can they do that and the fact if they
win this thing you know will people be
like well how did they win it do we need
to investigate them again
make sure they didn't have a camera out
in the outfield wall that doesn't count
doesn't [ __ ] count
it's a cheat meal for all houston
so um
anyway so i'm watching this series right
and i remember earlier this year i was
talking about dusty baker and saying
what a great manager you was
and then everybody called in yo yeah if
you wanna live
get you to the playoffs not [ __ ] win
all these [ __ ] losers who never did
[ __ ] with their lives start coming at me
and i'm like um
so you're telling me this guy
has been managing baseball teams for the
better part of [ __ ] 40 years
and somehow major league baseball's
getting it wrong but you
who never got picked in gym class know
the real deal
on dusty baker
so there's part of me
that i want
houston to win
also for their fans so they could say
well we did get a legit one
you know
but then there's the braves
you know you look at the braves
the braves have been to the winter
classic
okay they've been there five [ __ ]
times they've only won once
they have an 11 and 18 record they
actually lost in 95
no they won in 95 then they lost to 96
they lost in 99
that's 95 96 99
because
the indians lost in 97.
padres lost in 98 mets lost in 2000.
yankees lost in 2001.
wait who the [ __ ] did the angels beat i
can't remember
ah jesus christ that's a long [ __ ]
time ago anyway
so you know their fans are [ __ ]
tortured and who knew the [ __ ] astros
have been there three times
they lost an o5 to the [ __ ] uh
chicago white sox
which i thought really took the shine
off the red sox finally ending their
curse at the very next year you know the
white sox and the white sox win it
so i guess this is what's happening now
um they sort of stole our thunder you
know what i mean
that's like i remember when the last
episode of uh
you know seinfeld was coming out and
then the same week frank sinatra died
that's just one of those things like oh
man why couldn't frank died the week
before the week after i mean those are
two huge things you know they both
deserve their attention
uh houston also played a seven game
series in 2019 losing the decisive game
seven to the washington
nationals formerly
the montreal expos
anyway
so i'm going to watch that series if you
want to jump in
okay game three friday game four
saturday
game five sunday you have a nice [ __ ]
baseball weekend
you know and maybe send a message out
there to the amer major league baseball
that you know you don't need these ocean
elevens teams like they have in [ __ ]
uh nba's the same way
when david stern right
that's slippery little so-and-so
when they asked him who his dream nba
final was he said the lakers versus the
lakers because he didn't give a [ __ ]
about the league he gave a [ __ ] about
money and ratings that's all he gave a
[ __ ] about
um
but i'm sure it was all on the up and up
when the [ __ ] commissioner of your
league
not only would pick two teams that he
thought would be the best he picks the
same one twice
probably not a good look especially when
you bet get busted having a mobbed up
referee helping said team get to the
[ __ ] nba finals and win another one
oh
i am on a [ __ ] tear here
speaking of the arizona cardinals
everybody
um
they are paying playing the green bay
packers
on thursday night cardinals have not
lost yet this year so of course i'm
rooting for them to go undefeated
because i you know my team's in the afc
east and i'm so sick of the stupid
dolphins every year clinking their
glasses celebrating kids losing and not
getting to feel the feeling that they
did which i really just think is just i
don't know there's just something about
it that's just annoying
um
and not the fact that nowadays these
kids got to do it you know 16 17 times
they just that's just to get out of the
regular season
dolphins had to go 17-0 to win the whole
[ __ ] thing so
i don't know
i don't know sort of poor sportsmanship
if you ask me it's kanti is what it is
it's very chick energy estrogen you know
what i mean
cheering on the misery of somebody else
or german from what i am
scheid and freud
um
but i think this is the the green bay
packers season their season turns around
or they're just gonna [ __ ] level off
if they lose
okay because the the arizona cardinals
who would have thought are the big boys
in the nfc
uh
conference right
well the c does stand for conference
phil
in the nfc
in the a
afc
conference yeah you say afc east then
all the entire nfc that's what the [ __ ]
i'm trying to say so if the green bay
packers beat the cardinals they'd be
like you know what man hey man like i
know we're in [ __ ] wisconsin man
and everybody's up here eating cheese
but just know that man we can hang with
anybody in this league man
or they lose
and then once again it's on aaron
rodgers
to take that mom and pop store that is
the green and green bay packers
put it on his shoulders
and take it to the [ __ ] promised land
anyway i'm supposed to be doing these
[ __ ] reads here
oh here it is everybody
indochino
uh share a story of the time you felt
confident
with the look you put together i haven't
felt confident the way i looked in over
a year but i'm losing this [ __ ]
weight and i'll tell you right now when
i do i'm going down there and i'm gonna
buy one of those indochino suits and i'm
gonna start wearing a [ __ ] suit on
stage just for the [ __ ] of it
because you get a suit for 3.99 from
indochino uh describe the occasion the
outfit and how you felt
um let's see last time i wore a suit
uh i think on my anniversary i couldn't
fit in any of my suits
because i got all my suits tailored when
i was at my fighting my fighting weight
as dave kechner says when he's bob pogo
my fighting weight on f is for family
final season coming out
i don't know when
em told me yet
um
the right outfit can bring out something
special in us and with indochino
creating your best look yet could be
more affordable than you think you know
what's [ __ ] awesome about them i went
by the other day on melrose avenue they
have their own
store and i looked at the patterns and
the fabrics and they have like those
updated like [ __ ] suits that i saw in
the 70s you know some sort of crazier
patterns get a three-piece suit like
that a nice muted colored shirt right
underneath it coming in right
dick hanging to the left coming in
talking to the ladies
they think you're a [ __ ] weatherman
you know there's weather man groupies
out there everybody
uh the right i'm making all that up
except for the store
um indochino offers completely custom
fitted suits shirts casual wear and more
and more at surprisingly affordable
prices every piece is made to your exact
measurement and you can customize every
detail choose everything about your suit
from the fabric lapel monogram and
statement linings you can create a suit
that fits you and your style perfectly
the best part the best part of waking up
is putting on this suit indochino suits
start at just 3.99
with all customizations included
i always picture what's his face conor
mcgregor when he would have his [ __ ]
suits that fit him perfectly you can do
it for only 3.99 and you don't have to
learn how to choke somebody out
indochino is the poor man's conor
mcgregor suit indochino is now open at
select nordstrom stores giving you even
more ways to get great fitting
personalized clothing find your nearest
location at
indochino.com i i n d o c h i n o dot
com right now you can get fifty dollars
off any purchase at three nine and now
and more using code bur at checkout
that's fifty dollars off uh purchase of
399 and more at indochino
i-n-d-o-c-h-i-n-o dot com promo code
burr
simply safe everybody
you know there's big news from this
there's big news for my favorite home
security companies company simply safe
just launched their new wireless outdoor
security camera that's right simply safe
the system
um that u.s news and world report names
home best home security system of 2021
just got better the brand new outdoor
security camera is engineered with all
the advanced technology and security
features you want and need to help get
you to keep you and your family safe i'm
getting one of these [ __ ] things i'm
getting one of these things you know why
because i saw some raccoon paw prints
right next to my trash can and i want to
see what goes down when i go to bed
um jesus christ can you imagine if
you're watching there's some [ __ ] guy
out there jerking off near your trash
cans um it is an ultra
ultra wide 140 degree field of view so
you can keep watch over your entire yard
it has a 1080
p
or 1080p i don't know how to say that hd
resolution with an eight times zoom
that means you can zoom in on that
varmint and see what it's thinking look
right in its eyes
that means you can zoom in and clearly
see things like faces license plates to
capture critical evidence it has a
built-in spotlight with color night
vision
it's like you're in the [ __ ] army you
can keep an eye on what's going on day
and night it's super simple to set up
and usually just takes minutes
and it has an easy to remove
rechargeable battery so it doesn't need
an outlet and can go anywhere on your
property the camera has it all and it
integrates with your simply safe home
security system extending its
protection to the outside together it
means every door every window are
protected and now your property will be
too to learn more about the exciting new
simply safe wireless outdoor camera
with eight times zoom capabilities visit
simplysafe.com
once more that's simply safe
oh what's more simply safe is
celebrating this new camera by offering
20 off your entire new system and your
first month of monitoring service free
when you enroll in interactive
monitoring is there anything worse than
when somebody breaks into your [ __ ]
apartment which happened to me
and the cops are like well you know we
don't have any fingerprints there's
really nothing we can do
right
you got a camera you zoom in eight eight
times bam bam bam bam bam bam bam bam
bam right there that's his [ __ ] face
go get him
again that's simply safe
s-i-m-p-l-i-s-a-f-e
dot
not all of them work all right romans
everybody
romans
all right
the first people that took over the
world romans
all right when the moment up for inter
on some history breath actually that's
not true the huns came down and just
actually um marco polo actually you know
in india
romans the persian empire
if you read up on ancient medieval
history
romans
when the moment for intimacy arrives
you need to be ready
roman ready
whether you've been in a relationship
for years or just getting started having
the confidence that comes from
preparation
means you're free to enjoy the moment
when the moment comes even though you
are far from ordinary the truth is that
e.d
is really common in fact 52 percent of
guys age 40 to 70 experience some form
of erectile dysfunction
well 70 jesus christ i would think so
go to
getroman.com now to speak to a u.s
licensed healthcare professional about
erectile dysfunction and get 15 off your
first month of treatment you know bill
clinton's going down to get this [ __ ] ed
is more common than most people think in
fact 52 percent of men between the ages
of 40 and 70 will experience some form
of ed
roman's system is completely
confidential and totally discreet no big
logos or labels on packages with roman
you can get a free online evaluation yup
it's not going up and online ongoing
care for erectile dysfunction all from
the comfort and privacy of your home a
u.s licensed health care professional
will work with you to find the best
treatment plan if medication is
appropriate it ships to you free
[Music]
with two days shipping the whole process
is straightforward convenient and
discreet getting started is simple just
go to getroman.com
burr and complete an online visit take
care of your ed
without leaving your home complete an
online visit today to connect with a u.s
licensed healthcare professional and
take care of it go to getroman.com
today and if you're if you're prescribed
get 15 off your first month of ed
treatment
you're saving money
and your dick is saluting the flag again
i mean what more do you want make sure
you're ready to have confidence and
control this fall
roman ready
by the way
speaking of which i'm going to be i have
a weekend coming up when i'm in two of
my favorite cities detroit michigan
and i am in milwaukee wisconsin
all right i mean i can't even tell you
how [ __ ] excited when i go to those
[ __ ] cities
the uh
places to eat the people i just love
those places and uh it's it's very
exciting to see detroit slowly but
surely coming back
um
you know to have all of those cities go
through what the [ __ ] they went through
you know the whole rust belt was just a
[ __ ] shame and that's something i
always wondered
you know what it would have been like to
have caught those cities before
the rust belt when they were these great
cities thriving cities and people could
get jobs and those factories and all of
that [ __ ] granted i know they all
polluted the environment stuff but you
know
they're still polluting the environment
they're just in a different country now
those factories
but um
that always fascinates me um when we
used to make [ __ ] here
and now you could be in high school
and not even have to go to college and
you could go down the street
and get a job at one of these giant
factories that was so [ __ ] big you
could work there for 40 or 50 years and
never even see an employee that also
worked there for 50 years at the same
time until you both got your gold
watches
you know and you made cars or whatever
the hell you did
and uh
you know you could have yourself a house
you could have a stay-at-home wife
raise your kids
you know if you take all the racism out
of it i mean that's a hell of an america
hang on a second
um
anyway
so it's great seeing them come back
pittsburgh i swear to god
i'll name you right now now that i
talked about the fattest cities in
america cities i could live in
i could live in pittsburgh
i could live in milwaukee
um
chattanooga tennessee i loved
chattanooga the charm of nashville
without all the people milwaukee the
charm of chicago without all the people
pittsburgh
san francisco
without all those [ __ ] uh those those
guys not borch belt what do you call
those [ __ ] computer nerds who ruined
that city
pittsburgh is san francisco without all
those silicon valley [ __ ] [ __ ]
driving all the prices up up
those are my top three
top three right there and then when i
really really really
am down on human beings and just being
around other human beings
uh uh deadwood south dakota
i could live out in south dakota north
dakota i always forget or i could i
could live
in uh
i went to this place one time i did a
gig
in montana
what the [ __ ] was it butte montana
montana cities
see what do we got here wasn't helen i
think it might have been bozeman
or was it billings
one of those ones
just go up there and be one of those
weird white people that doesn't talk to
his neighbors
i really
every once in a while i feel like i
could be that guy
but then i think you know i'd miss all
my stand-up friends
you know there's a great burrito around
the corner
you know you get scared i mean that's a
commitment i mean anybody can be born in
the middle of nowhere and [ __ ] stay
out there
or be born in the city and stay in a
city but it takes a [ __ ] lot
to be in a city and then go move to the
middle of nowhere
or the other way around come to the big
city everybody's talking man
um
which by the way i finally saw that
movie urban cowboy
and i had no idea how [ __ ] dark and
creepy and all that [ __ ] the first time
i tried to watch i couldn't get through
it but i was also really scatterbrained
um
all right everybody
that um
before we end the podcast we have a
wonderful new addition to the thursday
afternoon just before friday monday
morning podcast it's the bet mg
segment where me and the great paul
verzi
the star of i'll say this on comedy
central
one of the great stand-up specials of
the last few years um
we pick we're battling each other going
head-to-head to see who who has the uh
you know who can pick all these nfl
games against the spread and here we are
this uh this is us talking about last
week's picks and who we like this week
enjoy
welcome back
for week eight of our mgm
nfl preview that's right the bet mgm
week preview okay as you guys know we've
teamed up with bet mgm and we are having
an absolute blast we're using the bet
mgm lines which are the best lines
okay to make all of our picks and we'll
have special offers for all our
listeners this week if you haven't
signed up yet
okay what have you been waiting for a
big splashy number to make your first
bet you've got the perfect oh we've got
the perfect offer for you sign up and
use bonus code bur that's b-u-r-r and
you could place your first bet risk-free
up to a stack that's right 1 000 if you
lose your wager you'll get your stack
back up to a thousand in free bets just
sign up with the bet mgm and make sure
you use bonus code burr that's b-u-r-r
and get your thousand-dollar risk-free
bet
um today here's the thing bill
bill and i
bill and i both went three and one and
we owned no bad i was hoping i was going
to go 4-0 i was 3-0 i know 3-0 and i was
like if i if versi goes three and one
and loses a game i'm gonna have his
heart
no that would have been demoralizing
dude we both went three and one and we
almost made these people win money with
our monday night special i got excited
about it actually it made me into the
game we had winston through a touchdown
not only did winston throw a touchdown
he threw it to camara which knocked out
two of our three bets in one play and
i'm going here we go let's cover and
they missed it by uh three points
but um yeah nothing is worse let's not
brag about almost making a money paul
let's brag about it when it happens i
know i was rooting for them though i was
rooting for the men um
is anything worse than being three and
oh and losing the last one that happened
to me too yeah winning a [ __ ] bet and
the asshole's going to the prevent so
you lose your bets you're actually
[ __ ] right but they decide to not
play football for the last two minutes
so don't get me started paul i'll choke
this [ __ ] microphone that's that's
the worst so i hit up i hit up andrew
and i go andrew i'm three and one what's
bill and he said you were doing the same
thing so we keep asking him and then he
goes bill's three and one so then i hit
up bill and i go we we both went three
and one and bill goes
oh the game's not over and i go what
game and he goes the game that's going
on now and i go no the game's still on
and he goes
why'd you say i lost already and i go oh
because he jinxed me paul that's what
you do you had this you compliment the
[ __ ] bookie you give them a shout out
to paul i mean we're still friends right
ah good week of football bill and you
know what oh you're still in the lead
you gotta ha you gotta you gotta have
like what two two three games on me i
did horrible in september
i think i got one game and then you got
that tie that that tie uh so i don't
know you're only a game up i think
you're at least two games
you've got to be at least two you had a
lot of three and ones when i went one
and three
in the last minute and even the week you
went oh and four i only went i only went
two and two so i picked up two games oh
maybe that picked up two games is big no
two get i went in the last four weeks i
went three and one three times but that
oh and four takes me i'm 14 and 14. i
know that i don't know what you are i
think it's a game difference i think i'm
definitely below 500 i'm on the hot seat
paul uh i got my house up for sale if
i'm coaching the [ __ ] mets right now
well here we go bill it is week eight
which is an even number right means it
is your turn to pick you going all right
i don't know why i'm going to pick this
game i don't i don't know why this game
is the way this game is
i feel like this is one of these games
you go like why the [ __ ] this looks like
easy money even though russell wilson is
not playing
they're giving three and a half to the
hapless jacksonville jaguars who i think
won their super bowl by winning last
week they're in seattle
they got the 12th man
the lumberjacks are coming out of the
hills
they're going to be deafening i'm taking
the seattle seahawks
laying three and a half to beat the
jacksonville jaguars
and with their ken doll quarterback
there
wow okay all right well i'm gonna pick a
game that i don't what the [ __ ] was that
what then you just made it sound like
that was a stupid move ever
i
i don't you want me to give you advice i
mean we're not giving each other advice
i don't like that pick i'll be honest
with you i'm not gonna tell you that
you're my friend i don't like the pick
because i think geno smith stinks and i
think seattle stinks and sneaky pete's
finito i think sneaky pete's leaving
soon that's my little [ __ ] side well
then take the jaguars
you can sit there and judge my [ __ ]
pics in front of everybody you son of a
[ __ ] you brought that out of me i tried
to mind my no i did not bring that out
of you you just went like
all right
you [ __ ] competitive son of a [ __ ]
no i swear to god you're trying you're
trying paul you're trying to put the hex
on all my picks oh no man you're going
to give you [ __ ] when you [ __ ] pick a
team laying 25 you got me all wrong
can you make eye contact with me look at
you no devon
[ __ ] red bastard
were you are you picking paul i don't
know man i think i'm gonna go i think
i'm gonna pick the packers to give the
cardinals their first loss thursday
night
but devonte adams is out but aaron
rodgers there's something about him that
when he's a dog and he's a road dog i
like him you know what i'm going to take
but we got to make sure these bed mgm
lines aren't moving do you got it at six
and a half i'm gonna take it a six and a
half i'm taking the green bay packers
and aaron rodgers giving
kai uh was it kyler murray and those
unbelievably undefeated cardinals their
first l i'm going with uh rogers i'm
taking the packers thursday night
you really gonna do that
[Laughter]
all right i got my next pick
is um
i am gonna take
joe burrow he's been making me money
he's going into the [ __ ] the
meadowlands which i don't even know is
paul is that even a professional
football arena anymore the way that jets
and giants have been playing lately the
giants held it up for years now i don't
know what happened they caught covent
from the jets i'm gonna take the bengals
paul layin
10 and a half
oof
this is a different year for you man
you're taking more points this year i
love it
i'm really paul you [ __ ] on all of my
bets i can feel it no
i did i did i just i you know what
should we go here's the thing bills they
just [ __ ] stink they just let the
patriots put like 50 [ __ ] points on
them
bill's beating me in the head to heads
andrew which means if we tie he wins
so if we tie by the way i beat you in
another head to head that's 3-0 can i
talk [ __ ] about that yet
i just three times paul you go up
against me and you lose and here you are
judging my bets in front of our
wonderful audience paul i'm telling you
dude your arrogance just knows no limits
dude i got i got a feeling i'm gonna go
own four this week i'm not gonna lie to
you like i can't see him it's like when
you're playing pool sometimes i can't
see the angles paul i hate this week too
i can't see it either dude i really
can't
um
you know the bucks have been crushing
why is the bucks lying so low against
the saints that one's [ __ ] with me
why are the bucks only favored by five
and a half because it's a divisional
rivalry paul
i was looking at that game
and the saints are at home and they're
getting five and a half
i personally i either take the saints or
i stay away from that game
oh i'm gonna do it bill i'm gonna do it
oh dude i didn't want to do it but it
just hit me i'm gonna do it
oh
i'm just gonna rip off the band-aid i'm
taking my giants getting 10 in kansas
city
i got to do it i got to tell you paul i
stayed away from that game because i
don't like kansas city's defense kansas
city [ __ ] stinks and sacrum how do
they stink they've gone to the super
bowl two years in a row they retain
their team what is going on in kansas
city their defensive backs their defense
stinks and i i don't know i'm to take my
giants getting 10 on the road i'm
starting the game i'm starting the game
10 nothing with my heart let's do it
betting with your heart paul that's a
dangerous thing
that is the gambling equivalent of
dating a stripper um
all right i got one my divisional
rivalry theory
those games usually are close
uh the bills are getting 13 and a half
playing the buffalo bills and i don't
know why
i don't know why those [ __ ] dirty
fish i'm gonna take the dolphins getting
13 and a half
okay
now wait a minute
are you [ __ ] with my bed again no no
no i'm ready oh you're looking at other
[ __ ] oh no i'm looking well i am so not
confident about my my things here i
actually need my bets this week i need
you
dude that was the third one i just go
i'm taking the dolphins getting 13 and a
half years ago
okay
what the [ __ ] is that that was me
looking at i'm looking at my bet i'm
sorry this isn't good for you paul and
this could go either way when the man is
looking at the [ __ ] bets right before
you it's not good
i i feel horrible this week i mean i
feel i feel dread maybe i'm wrong i
don't know if i'm not seeing it
all right so you're taking oh you're
taking the points is what you're saying
i'm taking the points you're taking the
points with the fish
i'm gonna fish it's available no one
cares
why didn't they go with the sharks the
sharks was open back the miami sharks
this is
tourism i'm taking the pittsburgh
steelers
the pittsburgh steelers getting three
and a half on the road
to the uh
the cleveland browns i usually i like
that pick is baker mayfield playing no
i like that pick
big ben
going into cleveland i mean he probably
has a [ __ ] time share up there he
does so well his whole career he's owned
those guys i don't know if he's going to
yell it afterwards like aaron rodgers
but
i like that pick all right bastard
all right i don't know why paul
i lost money last week betting against
the colts but i feel like the cults i
don't know i'm still not believing it
tennessee titans they got that that
derek henry i mean that guy's a problem
he's a problem in the first half he runs
in the first half the way you know
running backs having a big day running
the second half i'm going to take the
tennessee titans getting one point
in the house that that piece of [ __ ] jim
irsay lives in
i love that [ __ ] indianapolis i love
that i believe in mike grebel i think
he's a better coach
and uh i don't know i'm putting money on
uh
who the [ __ ] their quarterback raymond
tisdale what's the guy's name
what's that what's that quarterback's
name under my head i would say that
that's going to happen i love that pick
so good for you that should be a w in my
book now here you go you ready for this
one
i may this might be the biggest disaster
this might be a worse
alex
what's that who's the titans quarterback
the titans quarterback hey ryan ryan
tanner hill tannehill tannehill that's
it tana bomb
um all right
so
well maybe he does something this week
against the colts we remember his
[ __ ] name how about that paul i am
gonna do something stupid man i might
this might be the worst week ever i'm
taking the detroit lions
at home
getting
three and a half to get their first win
of the year they're [ __ ] 0-7 i'm
taking the cardinals to get their first
loss and the [ __ ] lions to get their
first win
there you go dude that is such a huge
game for the packers
that is such a huge game if they go in
there paul and they get their [ __ ]
asses handed to him
i feel like you know their season is
over
as far as a being a fan not saying
they're not going to make the playoffs
but just as a fan you got to be thinking
like all right
we are not we're not up to speed here
i think that's they got to win it i
think i think they go in there paul i
think they're going to be really focused
aaron rodgers are going to win that game
aaron rodgers going to win that game or
i like the points either way gun in my
head i i got arizona man
i just think kylo murray is going to be
like i'm going to show you who the new
mvp of the league is
you're coming into my house the
jobbingcenter.com
arena the worst [ __ ] name ever
all right anyways that's our picks for
this week paul i want to know how much i
thought you were at least two games
ahead of me
wait monday night special what are we
gonna do
let the monday night special
monday night with some money for our
listeners oh monday night specials my
giants and chiefs how are we going to do
that all right well we're going to do it
paul you're going to leave you for once
you're going to think about the
listeners paul
think about their hard-earned money
instead of your [ __ ] red blue and
white heart
all right what what what are we betting
on here
are we taking the points
you think the chiefs are going to cover
cover 10
i do
you do all right i mean i hate this game
i mean if you do i'll you could pick
that i'll pick another bet then you can
how is saquon barkley been playing he's
back now he was hurt
he's not an answer how's he playing when
he was before he got hurt he was playing
great he was back
then he got hurt oh he got hurt again
got an ankle twist a couple weeks ago so
he's not playing he is playing
but he's hurt and tony's playing
tony dungy who's tony tony time oh
cadarius tony it's tony time
florida gator rookie it's the [ __ ] dude
um well where's he been all year
he's been duties [ __ ] have an amazing
game dude he's having an amazing game 11
catches a hundred eight this is so
[ __ ] odd
this should we should not be able to
pick a monday night special when either
the patriots or giants are playing we
could you want to skip it we could skip
it or wait are you saying you're talking
about the knicks every year you actually
have me thinking that they're gonna do
well andrew can we do one where we don't
pick the money line where we pick like
other things can we do like this one's
going to get a touchdown this one's
going to do i say the chiefs just like
just like you're doing every week you
can pick money line you can pick
touchdown who's who to score first with
those chiefs are going to win that game
paul
you want to say daniel jones throws a
touchdown
nobody falls down on the 12-yard line
[Laughter]
um
how about he got the first down and then
he fumbles the ball can i bet on that
uh um
where's he from he's from duke right he
went to duke he got a duke university i
think i think he's done fumbling and
falling down i think he's smart enough
to know he finally figured out that he
is playing great he is playing great
um all right i say saquon barkley's
gonna get a touchdown i say this you
ready or do you want the florida kid how
about this i say patrick mahomes throws
a pic
paul you know what you're just like
this is like what is this what you want
to have happen
no i i think patrick mahomes is really
really struggling all right paul we're
going to say that
we're going to say throws i i saw the
confidence just drain out of your face
we're taking that
all right
this is off track betting paul on this
one
all right so we got yeah it's going to
be big on this one
a daniel jones tear up your tickets
paul's betting on the giants tear up the
tickets
he bet the horse
oh let's go let's go it's over all right
patreon i mean that's got to pay big
listen patrick mahomes throws a pick
daniel jones throws a touchdown and bill
likes the chiefs to you like to choose
to cover 10 money line
okay
oh this is going to be people are going
to be tuning in monday including me
it's a fun one well i'm going to be
rooting for you guys you know
i don't know why patriots always did
well against the church
something's wrong
that you know when when your wife is
talking about you when you know his got
family running around hotels fighting
he's got he's got things going on
there's a lot of things going on
internally and when that happens things
don't work on the field
we'll see i don't know paul some of my
best sets i get in a big fight with my
wife i go out on the stage and i [ __ ]
crush it
yeah but it's different you don't have
to throw [ __ ] touchdowns you can me
it's different it's what i do yeah but
it's it's what they do paul you vent
what do you think they're doing they're
going to take it out on the other team
well you know there's this new side of
you now you're like this psychologist
every week no he's probably this guy
went out to a hooters he's weighed down
with the wings and the blue cheese
but i can't knock it i mean you're up by
a couple of games i mean
no man dr paul i like this
if my wife was doing that i i i would it
would be good on stage not playing in a
professional game i'd be thinking about
it in the huddle
like i listen meg we're going to turn it
in his mind no you wouldn't she [ __ ]
did that paul you wouldn't no wait what
are we talking about what happened
no i just there's a lot of [ __ ] going on
in in the chiefs
outside how do you know how do you know
we where you getting this scuttle butt
i that's what i heard i was trying to
figure out what's going on with the
chiefs and i was like the chief stink
and somebody goes yeah dude you hear
about it you know i don't want to talk
about the guy's family you hear about
the guy's dad in a hotel and i was just
like all right i don't you know seems
like there's a lot of [ __ ] going on over
there so
you know you know that was kind of my uh
if i bet if you went around the league
there's a lot of [ __ ] going on in a lot
of you know these are [ __ ] true
that's true i could be wrong i could be
100 right okay
but let's hope there's nothing going on
in the chief's locker room they're just
a little out of step with each other why
are the chiefs this not like why are the
chiefs like you said go from that good
to this bad
very quickly i know paul why did you buy
those red gray and [ __ ] white nikes
just because it had jordan's silhouette
floating on it do you really like those
those are [ __ ] katrina's three those
those look like the ohio state ones
they bug me every week looking at that
no no don't don't say that i don't like
those [ __ ] a loudmouth ohio state
fans
look up look at the black
um i like those ones those ones are nice
so that's what we got we got mahomes
pick
we got the chiefs on the money line and
we got uh danny jones throwing a
touchdown
dude my home's picked dude that is a
[ __ ] that's got to be good odds like
that's got to be good money though right
of course it is we're betting the long
shot i bet it happens
giants d starting to play better we'll
see
paul if you're right about that if he
throws a pick
i'm gonna sing connie francis's i'm
sorry to you next week on the part
during this
what would you do if he thought i'm
sorry
what would you do so sorry huh what
would you do if he threw a pic and they
lost and then in the after interview he
just goes yeah man [ __ ] at home with my
wife
andrew play that play that andrew
he's got a lot of stuff going on you
know a lot of stuff going on at home
[ __ ] in the hotel you guys all heard
about that i'm sorry um all right let's
let's uh that's it everybody thank you
for listening to this i hope you guys
are winning some money we're having a
great time with bet mgm the best lines
in the business
sign up and use bonus code burr and you
could place your first bet risk free up
to a thousand dollars okay if you lose
your wager you get your stack back up to
a thousand in free bets paul versi
keeping his head above 500 i mean that's
that you mean we're in this is like
legit paul everybody thought it was a
fluke in september hey well verses been
on it make no mistake me and you both of
us this is a true statement here me and
you both have better records than some
professional nfl analysts right now and
i looked and that's that's maybe the
money line they're just picking we're
doing good we should be on tv
[Music]
all right that's it everybody
we'll talk to you next week have fun
watching
pro football we'll see you you have to
be 21 years of age or older to wager in
arizona colorado dc iowa indianapolis
michigan minnesota new jersey nevada
pennsylvania tennessee virginia west
virginia or wyoming only a new customer
offer paid in free bets visit betmgm.com
for terms and conditions uh excludes
michigan disassociated persons please
gamble responsibly gambling problem call
1-800 next step for arizona uh
800-522-4700 for colorado dc nevada
wyoming and virginia 800 270 717 for
confidential help michigan 1-800 gambler
indianapolis new jersey pennsylvania
west virginia 1-800 bets off for iowa
call or text the tennessee red line
call 800-889-9789
for minnesota a sports betting is a void
in georgia hawaii ohio and utah and
other states uh were prohibited uh
promotional offers not available in
nevada
all right everybody thanks again for
listening this has been the thursday
afternoon just before friday monday
morning podcast if you hang out
uh andrew themilas the greek freak as
paul verzi calls and we'll pick out some
interlude music here enjoy the music and
then we have a bonus thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast to help get you through your
your [ __ ] cardio or or your flight
across the country to one of the great
fat cities here in america
have a great weekend you [ __ ]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
stop trying to
[Music]
afraid
hey what's going on it's go burn it's
the monday morning podcast for monday
october 28th 2013.
three days before halloween everybody ah
the little bastards are coming
you know
they're all going to come walking up to
the door do you know the lovely nia has
canceled halloween for this year
she was so [ __ ] mad after last year
we went all out and i got the full-size
candy bars
right because i wanted to be that house
the [ __ ] good [ __ ] house dude you got
to go up the hill
yeah they got the full size once
you know like people would actually say
anything
the good people would
the future banker kids they wouldn't say
[ __ ]
you know
they'd sit there with their little
[ __ ] fisher-price pocket watch and
say nothing to see here then they'd
probably try to go back for seconds but
anyways
yeah i'm behind
i got to go get a pumpkin i got to make
my traditional pumpkin bread and you can
laugh all you want it's the [ __ ] and if
you ever had it you'd [ __ ] apologize
to me both verbally and in writing
that's how [ __ ] good my pumpkin bread
is i'll put it up against any of you
[ __ ] ladies
any [ __ ] women out there
huh
you want to go head-to-head with my
pumpkin bread you know what i say you
know what i say [ __ ] bring it
no enough i'm joking it's it's pretty
[ __ ] good though
should be
well goddamn vegetable oil in it be
[ __ ] moist to
february um but anyways
yeah last year there was just a like a
bunch of uh
like high school kids walking up with
barely a costume on they have that [ __ ]
eating grin
on their face you know that [ __ ] age
when kids get into high school and they
think they're smarter than adults and
they think adults are morons
because uh you know
what you know we're not listening to
their [ __ ] music or whatever the hell
it is
because they're starting to shave they
get that [ __ ] look on their face
which is hilarious i don't get mad at it
because
i did the same thing
it's really [ __ ] funny when you think
about it
that you would think that i guess
because when you look at adults we got
wrinkle wrinkles on our face we got the
pot belly they forget about the
experience
the life experience that we have like
we're not [ __ ] trying to do chin ups
here sir young man okay we're talking
about a little business transaction here
with your dumb [ __ ] fake mustache on
i know what the [ __ ] you're doing you
think i didn't do that at your age your
little [ __ ]
three whiskered [ __ ] get the [ __ ] off my
porch now see that's what i think we
should do i think we should still hand
out the candy
because nia is done with the whole
[ __ ] thing
um
i don't know if you guys listen to my
podcast from last year there was some
[ __ ] guy i don't know
i don't know where uh
what his accent was
but
he wanted some candy with his kids and
this guy was like
like three years younger than me and i
just was like really
really and he was just like yes
like really and he's like yes
i didn't know what to do
i [ __ ] choked in the moment and i
gave him candy i should have been like
get the [ __ ] out of here
what is your costume going as a [ __ ]
immigrant that's what you are that's
like me being a redheaded douche why
don't you give me some some of your
[ __ ] baklava whatever [ __ ] you make
so anyways but you know i don't want to
[ __ ] over the kids
kids are adorable
and you know if they're going to get
cavities i'd like it to come from this
house they're going to be future little
fat [ __ ] i'd like to start right here
on my front porch so i think she's
coming around
i think she's coming around we went to
the movies last night and we saw uh
gravity
we gotta find ourselves a new kind of
um
and that was [ __ ] amazing but you
know what sucks the last [ __ ]
like the last five times i've gone to go
see a movie in imax
you know neo always sets it up and i
always say look this is imax right
this is imax yeah it's yeah the timex
the timing there's like imacs and then
there's imax light
where it's the smaller screen the only
[ __ ] time i've ever gone to a movie
and i really saw it in imax is when i
saw the heath ledger batman
and that was one of those deals where i
couldn't see the cunt's head in front of
me and i felt like i was gonna fall off
the edge of the earth all right that's
imax what i saw last night was not imax
that was the that was the bud light
of imax where it's
it is a giant screen
but like to me imax is all you can see
is the screen in front of you
so [ __ ] annoying those douche bags
down there on universal city walk they
got like three imax ones they got the
real one
you know the alec baldwin won and then
they got the billy baldwin and the
[ __ ] stephen baldwin one and if
you're not careful when you go down
there they [ __ ] pass you off
you know not saying that it's not still
a good experience not saying that those
aren't two fine actors but it's not alec
patriotic it's not him
all right so last so i was a little
disappointed with that but other than
that was [ __ ] great sandra bullock
killed it
and um
jesus christ
um and it's just
just the thought of i think i could
actually uh
i could be at peace
floating away from a station and dying
that way and slowly just having the
oxygen go out
as lonely
as that would seem
just the [ __ ]
as long as i wasn't just twirling
through the air doing somersaults and
there's the earth and there's the sun
and there's the space and there's
there's the earth
i couldn't [ __ ] handle that if i was
just sitting there floating
looking back at earth and just sort of
drifting away i think that that would be
a pretty [ __ ] cool way to die
when you just gradually go to sleep i
don't know if you're breathing in only
carbon dioxide do you get like a
headache
i mean that that way it's such a [ __ ]
peaceful way to go
if you're gonna die before your time
okay
okay what do you have fallen off the
building [ __ ]
splat
right
that [ __ ]
put a [ __ ] wind in your ears you're
going down making noise
[ __ ] whatever noise you'd make on the
way down [ __ ] that
getting eaten like i i think
beyond what would you would you rather
get burned to death burned alive
or get eaten by a shark
i mean eating alive is [ __ ] brutal
like if i had to get eaten alive i'm
going with a big cat
big cat in africa it's [ __ ] over
after seeing the lion tamer there um
which really
that's that's really just a title
nobody tames a [ __ ] lion you
basically you had a good day you're
you're on a good run but you know what's
gonna happen eventually you know what i
mean that that's like getting an
honorary doctorate from a [ __ ] school
i have an honorary doctorate from
harvard great well you're not smarter
than anybody or you're not even as smart
as anybody who went to this school you
just wrote the macarena or you [ __ ]
had your own sitcom
you know and they knew that all those
eggheads were going to be boring as hell
when they were giving speeches on
graduation day so they brought you in
you're a [ __ ] clown and they give you
a piece of paper that's the same thing
with lion tamers
all right
you
you're not taming them
okay you're trying to break their spirit
but at the end of the day they're a
[ __ ] lion and they're the king of the
beast
okay although some would say that the
bengal tiger could kick the [ __ ] out of
a lion
i don't know about kick the [ __ ] out of
him but uh
i don't know but anyways just watching
that uh that line tamer in vegas like
when that thing
grabbed him
by the throat that dude went limp in
like [ __ ] two seconds it was like
when you watch the ufc
you know when someone gets choked out
you get choked out real [ __ ] quick so
i i don't have i wouldn't i wouldn't
want to get mauled like i wouldn't want
to get attacked by a bear they're very
sloppy
you know i mean they're very like rip
your face off and uh you know eat a
little bitty and then come back later
after they took a nap kind of [ __ ] i
like that lions tigers they just get
right to it they grab you by your
[ __ ] throat in two seconds that's it
you're out
you're dead it's over and then they you
know
and they have a meal
i wonder if any of us taste better than
the others like if you ate healthy
if you're like a if you eat like a
macrobiotic diet if you're like a grass
like grass-fed cattle
as opposed to an [ __ ] like me smoking
cigars drinking booze occasionally going
to mcdonald's do i do i taste more like
you know drake's cakes
some dried out [ __ ]
i don't know but anyways when you look
at all those and then the worst
of all the getting eaten alive other
than a [ __ ] komodo dragon which would
basically bite you and then slowly
follow you around
for the next three days as the poison
takes over you know
as you're laying there
and the thing's like two feet away
you know just staring at you it's lizard
tongue flicking at the side of your face
but not eating you you know that's
[ __ ] horrific
um
plus you know rep reptiles just they
just don't they just don't have any
there's there's no emotion
they're heartless
they don't give a [ __ ]
mammals even like a lion or something
they they have some sort of
understanding what the [ __ ] it is
they're doing just like
you know reptiles are like the
terminator
not even
terminator could talk i don't know what
the [ __ ] they are but they freak me out
i don't i don't like them i really don't
i respect mammals i have i i don't like
reptiles
there i made that statement and i'm sure
i'm going to get some backlash on that
and i'm prepared to go on cnn and defend
myself when i go and split screen with
some [ __ ] lizard lover
but anyways so if you're floating
through space like i could die like that
i definitely could as long as i wasn't
cold as long as that suit held up and i
was just sort of floating
that would kind of be
the most uh
that would be the ultimate premature
death
if you're going to die in your 30s 40s
or whatever god i still had half my life
ahead of me or whatever um
as long as i wasn't tumbling if i was
just sitting there floating looking back
at the planet
for the last 20 years of my life and
that's pretty [ __ ] awesome
you know me and lance bass up there just
hanging out
i don't [ __ ] know i have no idea so
anyways um i am uh seven days in no six
days in
no booze
shut it down
i'm getting the glow back
all right i've been juicing
um although yesterday was a bad day
exercise day for me i just sat on the
couch all [ __ ] day
and gave a [ __ ]
you know just watched sports all day and
gave a [ __ ]
it was the worst i watched that patriots
dolphins game
with uh right on right out right out of
the gate uh my thanks to the officiating
crew
uh that that worked that game i i am
trying to remember the last time i've
watched a game where my team
got so many [ __ ] huge calls to keep
the drive going
that pass interference call on gr uh on
that defensive back against gronkowski
was criminal
criminal i believe that gave us kept the
drive alive we got three points on that
one and then they had the phantom hands
to the face
flag thrown three like three four
seconds after the play ended
travesty
and then there was the fumble
and they said the dolphin slapped it
forward or what i mean that's one of
those borderline was he reaching forward
or whatever but after those other two
[ __ ] ones we get the benefit of the
doubt again brady got sacked he fumbled
the ball and the ball went 10 yards back
in the other direction we got the ball
back and it was first down lost 15 yards
and still somehow it was first down and
uh
we were able to come back and beat him
and i gotta say um
the patriots are are over achieving this
year
um
it's really an unreal i can't believe
the record that what are we six and two
is that what it is we lost to the jets
and we lost to the bengals
but uh you know
i'm i'm not like i'm a realist i know
what's gonna happen we play the broncos
i know what's gonna happen if we played
the seahawks or if we played the colts
or even the 49ers look i know belichick
is a [ __ ] genius
and that we can somehow i don't know
what but at this point
you know that was what was driving me
[ __ ] nuts yesterday
is they start the goddamn game
and they talk about how the patriots
have injuries at all three levels on
their defense we're missing our best guy
vince wilfork our defensive line
best guy plus kelly our best linebacker
mayo is out for the season our best
corner a key to lieb
they're all out
they're all [ __ ] out hernandez went
to [ __ ] jail gronk just got back
amman dole is [ __ ] in it we got we
got nothing going on
you know
so they addressed that
and then the end of the game
i'm watching hall of fame [ __ ]
players talking about brady's numbers
and how how his numbers are down and
going this is an atypical i mean tom
brady with 125 yards passing
it's like you just [ __ ] said
how about tom brady
somehow we're [ __ ] six and two with
nobody
[ __ ] nobody we got nobody we got
gronk back but we got [ __ ] nobody and
we're somehow winning goddamn games and
um
i don't know so i am a realist so
despite the fact that we're six and two
you know i know i know the hammer's
coming down i know it is yeah even if we
win the division all that i mean i'm not
delusional
at all
and then
after i'm dealing with that [ __ ] i
actually call up mercy to talk about
these [ __ ] [ __ ] analysts
and
ferzie
i'm going to start
he's just sprinkling his fairy dust on
the new york giants like every [ __ ]
week right
they're 0-1 two and he's just going like
dude you know i think we're gonna win
next week oh and three dude i think
we're gonna win next week oh and four
dude
oh and six right
and he starts going like dude you know i
think we can go on a [ __ ] run here
and blah blah blah right so now they've
won two weeks in a row
okay and i know they're not they're
nowhere near as bad as their [ __ ]
record but
furzi [ __ ] yesterday did the classic
paul versi
okay i remember in in when the patriots
played the giants the first time in the
super bowl right before the super bowl
starts he goes dude i'm telling you i
you know i i think the giants could
surprise some people today
that's what he said i think they could
surprise some people today he he wasn't
saying they are he wasn't putting any
money on it he just threw it out there
which is perfect because if they do he
gets to be like dude what i say and then
if they didn't he goes well i just said
you know i just had a feeling
[ __ ] that non-committal [ __ ] so now
he goes
the the af the nfc [ __ ] east is so
[ __ ] pathetic this year
the giants started oh and six they're
now two and six and they're only two
games out of first they could actually
win their division
all right which is
which is classic giants the last like
seven years it's just like the planets
aligned for these guys it is their
[ __ ] time so what does verzi say
yesterday he goes dude i tell you i i i
think they could go on a run they get in
the playoffs and then they they they
could they could win the super bowl
perfect
perfect [ __ ] prediction
didn't say they're gonna
didn't put any money down he throws it
out there so i'm guaranteeing you if if
if the giants win the [ __ ] super bowl
he's gonna go dude i called it because
he threw it out there i swear to god
it's listening to that guy predict [ __ ]
it's like watching a guy play roulette
who just comes up with chips and just
[ __ ] dumps him on a bunch of
different numbers
ah [ __ ] it drives me insane
and please send this clip to him
you don't even need to because i'm going
to give him [ __ ] about it today
um and i actually like the giants and
that type of thing and i think that they
could go on a [ __ ] run and who knows
if they get healthy i mean who knows but
i mean i don't know i i don't see them
uh
i don't know the saints the [ __ ]
seahawks there's a lot of guys to get
through
you know what i mean but i mean the way
the white the reason why the nfl's great
is everybody does have a [ __ ] shot
especially if you play in the [ __ ]
nfc uh east
but um i don't i'm gonna give him some
[ __ ]
i'm gonna tell him right now i'm gonna
call that [ __ ] today
all right and i'm gonna say listen
i want you to put money on it right now
that the giants are gonna win the
[ __ ] super bowl all right and if you
don't put money down on it then i don't
want to hear a [ __ ] word out of you
strive you know
you know what's a classic paul versi
pick uh xander bogarts
i was watching that [ __ ] you know just
watching the guy i heard a little hype
about him i read a little bit about him
and then i watched like two at bats and
i'm watching this 21 year old kid
working the count in the [ __ ] world
series
and uh i'm like this is a versi pick
right here
he would jump on the bandwagon dude i'm
telling you i think this kid could do
something
oh is he gonna be pissed at me
i'm just [ __ ] with you paul but for
the love of god just say some shit's
gonna happen and put some [ __ ] money
on it stop with your [ __ ] uh i'll
tell you you know i think it could rain
this week
um all right plowing ahead here uh
a lot of sports this [ __ ] week as
always i feel really bad because i've
been neglecting my bruins
i know we lost to the devils and i know
we beat
i think we beat san jose crazy in our
last second shot i've just been
wrapped up watching baseball
and uh
i gotta tell you dude i did not miss it
watching playoff baseball when your team
is in it will take [ __ ] 30 years off
your life per game
and um
and i know that's not a unique
experience i know tigers fans have gone
through it and i know cardinals fans
have gone through it certainly with us
being two
two games a piece and um
i gotta tell you it's been exciting but
i [ __ ] hate baseball
i i can't handle watching the [ __ ] i
hate that there's no [ __ ] clock
it just
i i hate that you just can't [ __ ] win
a game easily you can't just be up
a bunch of [ __ ] runs and everything's
good you can't just be up four to one
and it's all good you know at some point
between the sixth and the eighth inning
the other team is somehow he walks the
first guy on base and then it's just
gonna be this [ __ ] nightmare and then
they're gonna take the guy out some
other [ __ ] stiff is gonna come in
and it's just
i have tourette's
when i watch it i have to walk away i
have to go in the other room i have to
put the thing on mute because i'm
convinced tim mccarver
hates the red sox and the yankees i
learned that he hates the yankees
through verzi and uh you know he's a
former cardinal i just think he just
[ __ ] and i'm really trying to listen
objectively going is this guy
criticizing the cardinals the way he's
criticizing slash predicting
possible bad [ __ ] for the red sox
[ __ ] guy drives me up the goddamn
wall
um
any or he says positive [ __ ] about ortiz
and positive [ __ ] about uh xander
bogarts and other than that
it's just gloom and doom with that guy
drives me up the [ __ ] wall but um i
have no idea who's gonna win this series
and uh it's been a great series so far
and two of the most bizarre endings to
games
games out three and four and that uh
that obstruction thing i'm not gonna be
a [ __ ] and complain about it um i don't
know what the rule is like most baseball
fans
the first time i saw the definition of
it was that night and uh i i don't
[ __ ] know i mean
i think it's
more positive way of looking at is
probably we shouldn't have thrown the
ball down to third base
slash we probably should have caught the
ball and uh i don't i don't know how you
call obstruction when you miss
the first the first half of the
collision that would be my only part of
it but it seemed like everybody
including our own manager said they got
it right so uh so they got it right
the [ __ ] you gonna do um
whatever
it's tied up to anybody's [ __ ] game
and i hope we're gonna win
obviously i want the red sox to win but
i really want us to win because
i can tell how much versi wants us not
to win
how much he [ __ ] hates the red sox
and their [ __ ] beards
and their anti anti-yankee dress code
it's driving him
like the level that he gives a [ __ ]
makes me laugh because it reminds me of
the ridiculousness of why do i care it's
like
especially with versions like why the
[ __ ] dude you got 27 championships if we
win this one it's our eighth
what is the problem
but he for some reason
[ __ ] hates the red sox
you know for the most part other than oh
four in the last [ __ ] nine years
we've done nothing but wonderful things
for the yankees and you know you'd think
if chicago could find it into in their
hearts to to thank us
you know you'd think that a yankee fan
like virgin could say something nice
you know but i don't think he has it in
him
um i'm just [ __ ] with them all right
let's let's do a little advertising here
for this week uh what do we got here
what do we got the usual oh this is this
is the one that's been blowing up and
i've been getting nothing but positive
reviews everybody are you a man
that probably means you got to shave
right unless you got that [ __ ] kid
disease
where you never get any whiskers because
your parents smoke too much weed or
whatever the [ __ ] however you get that
disease is that a technical disease i
don't know what it is
um dollar shave club everybody
there's so many things in the world that
irritate me
um
people who had no idea what the
obstruction rule was and then watched it
on espn and then start breaking it down
like they went to law school
that irritates me
um
what else irritates me i don't [ __ ]
know
the fact that i've been eating so well
and doing great and then i went to the
movies last night got a kit kat and
peanut [ __ ] m m's like that wasn't
enough sugar
you know
that irritates me a bunch of stuff
irritates me anyways when so many things
can irritate you
why would you add razors to that list
it's time to stop milking your razor
blades everybody i know with brand name
razors you're used to paying outrageous
prices and exhausting those raises and
razors until they start looking like a
rusty soda can well guess what it's time
to move on dollar shave club delivers
amazing quality blades right to your
goddamn door for just a couple of bucks
a month so you never have to think about
it again they sent a pack every month so
you can change your blade every week i
love these guys and your face is going
to love them too they also have a new
product called a one wipe charlie
one wipe charlie's everybody what is it
it's a butt wipe for men and it's classy
you wipe your ass with your pinky
hanging out
um
check out check out the video and sign
up for your raises today go to
dollarshaveclub.com forward slash burr
that's dollarshaveclub.com
forward slash bar or go to billboard.com
and click on the dollar shave club
banner alrighty there you go hulu plus
everyone
you've probably tried hulu.com well
guess what now it's time to try hulu
plus you can watch your favorite shows
anytime anywhere hulu plus lets you
watch thousands of hit tv shows and a
selection of acclaimed movies on your
television or the on or you can use the
on your go with the uh the smart phone
or to what what the hell did i just say
there or on the go
with your smartphone or tablet i was
doing so well and it all streams in hd
for the best viewing experience possible
with hulu plus you can watch your
favorite current tv shows like saturday
night live community and family guy you
could also check out exclusive content
including hulu originals like the
awesomes starring snl seth meyers and
soon to be late night talk show host
seth meyers and moon boy starring chris
o'dowd from bridesmaids hulu plus also
offers a great selection of acclaimed
films for only 7.99 a month you can
stream as many tv shows and movies as
you want wherever you want you can't
beat that deal right now you can try
hulu plus for free for two weeks when
you go to huluplus.com
bill that's a special offer for my
listeners everybody make sure you use
huluplus.com bill so you can get the
extended free trial and that they know
that we sent you go to huluplus.com bill
now or click on the hulu plus banner on
the podcast page at billboard.com there
you go
um anybody watch fast and loud this week
i taped a bunch of episodes and i have a
new favorite car i've always been a ford
guy
and um
the dude kc on the show who paints the
cars which i think is so [ __ ] badass
i was never really into the body work at
first i was into watching them you know
do the suspensions and dropping motors
in and that type of thing but over
the uh you know
years of watching the [ __ ] on youtube
and watching people redoing cars and
stuff i'm really starting to get into
the
you know knowing how to paint the car
just and it looks so [ __ ] easy but i
watched richard do it one week and he
sucked at it
so i really see that there's an art to
it but anyways that dude kc on the show
had this uh 55 ford custom line
and uh i think that's what custom line
or custom liner i'd never heard of it i
was always sweating the [ __ ] bel airs
thinking that chevy was doing it right
and uh let me look this up here
yeah uh custom line and they redid that
one and they painted it [ __ ] all
white
they took the chrome off of it that car
was the [ __ ]
and then they ended up selling it to uh
mark cuban
of the dallas mavericks
and uh
i swear to god if you ever get sick of
that car i'd buy it
i'd buy it off him i don't know if i pay
what the [ __ ] he paid for it i don't
have that kind of money but jesus
such a badass [ __ ] car so anyways
um i'm in town
after you know i've been on the road
this whole basically this entire year
and i got a two week break here and i've
been really enjoying myself just hanging
around the house finally
um
i got back into playing drums a little
bit i'm doing that mike johnston 10 days
to faster hands workout i highly
recommend it i'm six days in as of today
i'm finally able to stick with it just
because you know when i travel i kind of
barnstorm around where it's like a
different city every night
and it's really hard you know you bring
a practice pad and your drumsticks and
trying to find a table high enough it's
a big pain in the ass so uh making sure
that i'm doing it this time i'm sticking
with it
and um
anyways i'm getting back into all my all
my hobbies
uh
believe it or not this week i'm actually
gonna try to make homemade ravioli
i don't know i'm all over the [ __ ]
map nia said that to me the other day
she goes you're all over the map you
have add you can't you play drums you
play guitar you make pumpkin bread
you know
you can fix cars a little bit the
outskirts basically
i can't really fix cars i can do a
little [ __ ] on it i could have
[ __ ] up my seatbelt i got to put that
in that's a couple of bolts i can handle
that [ __ ] whatever
you ride motorcycles a little bit you're
all over the [ __ ] map and i was like
wait a minute
but i stuck with stand-up comedy i've
been doing that almost 22 years straight
she goes yeah well you know
yeah well you know that's the [ __ ]
thing i do everything else
the other [ __ ] i do
is that right cleo
look her over there she got her two beds
stacked up on each other like a [ __ ]
double cheeseburger
never seen anything sleep more in its
life than that dog oh by the way i'm
doing a i'm doing a benefit this sunday
sunday sunday sunday i'm doing a benefit
um
for uh for pit bulls
rescue pit bulls and it's gonna be down
at uh largo theater this sunday
that would be november
second or third november third
i'm gonna be down there um with a bunch
of other comedians a bunch of dog lovers
uh who the hell else is on it i can't
remember me whitney cummings couple
other people and uh
i did this benefit last year
and it's a great cause and what's even
it's even better is they bring a bunch
of pit bulls down there
and uh
it's really is my favorite [ __ ] dog
it's just the best they get the best
heads
they're [ __ ] jacked
you know
you should see my dogs my dog's legs
it's ridiculous her back legs when she
goes to stretch i'm telling i've said
this before you remember that road
runner
um episode
where wiley coyote took that [ __ ] to
make him run really fast and he's
running he had the flames remember that
he took it was like roids for his thighs
that's what her [ __ ] legs look like
um
and every morning she wakes up and i
squeeze him like shaman
um all right hey last week i talked
about the greenpeace 30
and how they got arrested for piracy and
just like was there any sort of thought
behind you know
if you boarding a goddamn russian
i don't know drilling platforming what
the [ __ ] did you think was gonna happen
so they got arrested for piracy and i'm
gonna really follow this uh
um i'm really gonna follow this story to
see what happens it's it's just insane
like right now they are
first of all it got dropped down
let's see here green greenpeace arctic
arctic 30s plight highlights the
inhumanity of russian jails all right
that's a different one
um it's now a month now
since the 30 greenpeace activists
arrested for attempting to board the i'm
not going to try to say it
why not i'll give you a laugh
[ __ ] oil platform
we're transferred from police lockups
to remand prisons in merman's the
merman's region in the arctic circle
that really scared the [ __ ] out of me
like i literally thought that they were
on just
they built these jails on the ice but
it's sort of the
one of the most
northwest i think it's the most
northwest city
in russia
basically uh at a butts up against like
finland
sweden norway like the top of those
countries so they're kind of all the way
up there
in these goddamn jails and um
where the hell is it here they they
actually were able to uh
they reduced the charges so they're now
russian drops piracy charges cuts
maximum jail term in half
activists face up to seven years in
prison if convicted
basically they they i think they knocked
it down to uh
i don't know almost like hooligan
behavior
says russia on wednesday dropped the
piracy charges against 30 people
involved in a greenpeace pro
sorry about that the batteries cut out
on me um speaking of greenpeace i was
trying to make sure i used up all my
other batteries before i [ __ ] throw
them out because i don't know where the
[ __ ] to recycle them
um where the hell was i
um
i'll just start it over again they drop
the piracy charges blah blah blah blah
blah they face up to seven years down
from 15 years the charges against the
activists who protested the platform
um
last month have been changed from piracy
to hooliganism
the federal investigative committee said
and there's a whole greenpeace thing if
you guys want to get involved and try to
help to get these knuckleheads out of
jail
um
i don't know like
protesting this is a really sad truth
protesting is difficult enough in your
own country even if you have a democracy
because you know the cops are going to
show up you know what the deal is and as
much as you tell everybody just remain
peaceful and then they won't club us
down somebody eventually ends up
throwing a rock
or doing something or some conspiracy
theorists say that that the government
hires somebody to go in with the
protesters
and throw something so then the cops can
then beat him down and tear gas them i
don't know if that's [ __ ] true but
i'd love to think it is
um
it's hard enough to [ __ ] do it in
your own country i gotta give it up the
[ __ ] balls those people had
to try and do that um
and just the situation that they're in
it reminds me of that documentary i saw
in that the ganja queen did you guys
ever see that
it was basically this lady
that went to uh bali
and
according to her she loaded a boogie
board
with a boogie you know
she checked that and that was her
carry-on and then when she got off
the uh the plane
the uh bali state [ __ ] troopers
came over and said hey is that your
boogie board
[ __ ] satchel and she goes yeah it is
and then they opened it up and there was
all this weed in there
it was all this weed man
and they don't in indonesia they don't
[ __ ] around
when it comes to uh drugs they have a
zero tol zero tolerance for it and if
you get busted with the [ __ ] i think
they put you to death is what they
usually do
and they say that i just did tom rhodes
podcast and we we kind of started to
talk about this
and
they basically uh i s he's been to bali
and i was like dude don't you get scared
and you sort of laugh because no i just
don't bring any drugs into the country
and
i'm just kind of like well
what if just something happens
what if somebody next to you has them
and just shoves them in your pocket i
know that's a ridiculous fear but like
you know what i mean look
i'll go to another country and i and the
countries that if you kill somebody it's
punishable by death
and i ca i can live within that because
i
just can be like well you know i'm not
going to kill anybody i think it's
because over here
if you get busted with weed in a lot of
states now it's legal
and then
then if you get busted it's like no big
deal
unless of course you have a bunch of it
and you get you get busted for
trafficking that's a whole other deal
but i mean it's not like somebody can
just drop
a bunch of kilos of weed on you and
plant that on you stick them in your
[ __ ] backpack you're gonna know
they're there
but just the fact that you have one
goddamn joint on you
like dude i would walk into that country
naked
i come in with a [ __ ] speedo i'd get
a colonic the week before i would juice
for a [ __ ] month
and uh
i would have a cattle prod and keep all
other passengers away from me and i
would walk into there wearing a goddamn
thong and that's the only way and even
then i would be scared
punishable by [ __ ] death jesus christ
so anyways if you if you if you want to
watch something really disturbing
um watch this ganja queen it was what
she was called in the papers over there
they opened up her boogie board
uh satchel or whatever the [ __ ] you call
it carry-on case and there was a bunch
of weed in there and uh
she they
they were like we're gonna put you to
death
in the australian whatever the [ __ ]
syndicate whatever you call it the
embassy tried to get this woman out of
it
and uh
just watch that documentary this this i
mean obviously the green piece 30
they're not going to get put to death
but
sitting here scrolling across the maps
here
looking at this [ __ ] where bali is over
and there's murmansk there it is right
there jesus christ
i just [ __ ] that how the [ __ ] is anybody
gonna help you
oh my god
that's why i always do that amnesty
international because that is a [ __ ]
fear of mine just being thrown in a
goddamn jail do you ever watch remember
that show arrested abroad did you ever
see that thing i watched that with nia
one time and nia loves traveling she
goes that that made me never want to
[ __ ]
go anywhere
again in my life but it just was one of
those things it was always like these
[ __ ] people were trying to smuggle
drugs
out of the country i mean i'm trying to
think of something that takes more balls
than that
i'm sure that you guys can come up with
something
but i you know i just being in a country
where if you get caught you're going to
go into their goddamn
gulag
and you're not going to be able to speak
the language you mean talk about a man
without a [ __ ] country and you're
gonna have to go in there
i mean jean-claude
van damme is he's in at the height of
his powers is getting [ __ ] ass raped
in that situation it's just you're done
you're [ __ ] finished
jesus christ
i mean i get not working in a cubicle
and wanting to make you [ __ ] money
but i there there's got to be some other
talent that god gave you where you can
make money that doesn't involve shoving
a key or coke up your [ __ ] ass trying
to get out of colombia
there's got to be another way to do it
right
riding your [ __ ] moped to the airport
on unpaved roads
this just happened there has to be a
better way
it's got to be a better way to do it
um
anyways let's [ __ ] move on here let's
let's are we far enough into the podcast
here now that the thing cut out i got to
do the math here was a 35
ah jesus i don't [ __ ] know let's uh
let's read a um
i think i went through everything that i
wanted to talk about didn't i
oh yeah i'm a little out of it here i
haven't eaten yet today because last
night i ate late late at night i ate it
like a
like one in the morning i think is when
i finally stopped eating
um
came home had one of those [ __ ] uh
anti-pasta plates and uh like [ __ ]
one in the morning and i had here by
that rule
that you go 12 hours with after your
last meal like if you eat at 8 o'clock
at night eat the next day 8 in the
morning i stayed up till 1 in the
morning so i'm not eating until 1 in the
afternoon all right that's how you
become a tub of [ __ ] right you go to bed
at one you wake up at 7 30 in the
morning you have to go to work and then
you eat a bacon egg and cheese or a
[ __ ] doughnut and it's over
it's [ __ ] over
so uh that's it i i tell you i got down
to like [ __ ] a buck 70.
i told you i was going to get into uh
sitting down no shirt on shape
that's what i want to get back to just
one more [ __ ] time
in my life you know they're always
making these movies
you know they're going to do it one more
time they got one coming out that i'm
going to go see that that one with de
niro uh uh michael douglas
and [ __ ] uh morgan freeman
alan arkin or where i think he's in
there i don't know if they're all in
there but like i'm gonna go see you know
they're doing it one more time right
that's what the [ __ ] i'm doing with my
stomach
and uh i'm having a hell of a time
because if you just stop eating you end
up losing muscle all of a sudden i
looked down on my arm i had the arms of
a seventh grader and i still had my
little [ __ ] beer belly
you know looking like a goddamn turtle
right now
so i gotta do something i gotta i gotta
[ __ ] eat more meat and [ __ ] do uh
more i don't know what i gotta do
probably have to get a personal trainer
i don't wanna do that
i have somebody holding my ankles and
i'm doing sit-ups i can't [ __ ] do
that [ __ ]
[Music]
oh speaking of michael douglas you know
i finally sat down and i watched behind
the candelabra
you know
i am um i i'm too homophobic i was too
homophobic to watch it
and uh
you know
this is the thing about being homo being
homophobic there's all different levels
of it
like that word oh he's homophobic and
then you get it like you think
gays are going to hell and they
shouldn't be married and what they're
doing is unnatural i'm not homophobic
like that
um
i think you know being gay is just how
you're naturally wired so it's
completely natural and go out and
[ __ ] have at it
you know
[ __ ] as many as you can
do your thing
don't give a [ __ ] get married
have a hell of a [ __ ] time
you know god bless you
but uh i i get like uh i don't know what
it is in movies
when there's guys kissing each other and
caressing each other i it makes me
[ __ ] uncomfortable and then there was
something about watching michael douglas
and matt damon
playing footsie with each other like
that [ __ ] i i didn't want to see him
in a hot tub together
i i couldn't [ __ ] watch it
i'm getting uncomfortable talking about
it but whatever i'm being honest
so anyways i was on the road or
something i don't know where the [ __ ] i
was at i was back in boston and it came
on and i watched
the second half of it and i gotta tell
you something that was it was absolutely
[ __ ] phenomenal
it was [ __ ] hilarious here at some
point and do her michael douglas
impression
going scott
scott i can't i can't do it as well as
she can um
they will they what
michael douglas and matt damon killed it
in that [ __ ] movie and uh
and i was actually rooting for matt
damon's character i felt bad for him
it's like dude you got to get out of
this relationship you're [ __ ] up your
face you got to get off the drugs
you know
he's bringing in some younger guy you
the writing's on the wall you got to get
out of here man go take some night
classes
you know
do something else the [ __ ] you doing
with this old man
this sparkly [ __ ] coats in this
goddamn toupee
you know what i mean he's using you i
got into it like that that's how well it
was done
um i highly recommend that two thumbs up
behind the candelabra oh [ __ ]
homophobe billy he liked it
um not 100 homophobe 20
homophobe
um
is that offended offensive to say
homophobe am i supposed to say
homophobic there's something about
abbreviating [ __ ] that makes people
annoyed like you're not supposed to say
[ __ ] anymore
and you know what's funny i don't even
know if that's short for transvestite or
transsexual
i don't understand why that's bad
that's like if he names mike and
somebody hey mikey
is that bad you know that's really
offensive my name is michael thank you
very much
transvestite [ __ ]
what do you say there dick and address
what are you doing there buddy
sweetheart you know you can't [ __ ]
say that evidently
despite if in your heart you don't think
there's anything wrong i don't give a
[ __ ] if that's what you want to do god
bless you
you know god bless you
put on some [ __ ] heels walk down the
street and let people know what you're
doing
um i don't give a [ __ ]
i really don't
i really don't just [ __ ] don't play
your music too loud
don't trick-or-treat past a certain age
and uh
i don't know what else if you're drunk
i don't mind if you talk to me when
you're drunk just you know keep your
distance
is there anything worse than what
somebody's i had somebody over the
weekend
i was down at the comedy store and just
somebody was [ __ ] wasted and they
just you know somebody's wasted when
they just come up to you you're in the
middle of a conversation is yes yes
[ __ ] bard they become like you know
like toddlers don't give a [ __ ]
how they they have no concept of two
people talking they'll just barge in on
the conversation
and they'll just i think i used to do a
bid on this i don't even know if i ever
put it on a special i used to talk about
how they look like they were like drunks
and they would just start in the middle
of the conversation middle of a story
and let you try and figure it out
um
i don't want to talk about let's let's
let's read uh let's read some of this
[ __ ] here um
all right is 29 too old
hey there billy bandwagon for those of
you who don't follow me on twitter i uh
been going by bill bandwagon
watching the red sox and uh
i gotta tell you right now i am not bill
bandwagon anymore after [ __ ] aging 30
years watching all of these goddamn
games i am back to die hard i'm not die
hard maybe i am maybe maybe i'll come
back to watching uh
baseball we'll see the jury is out but
uh
bill bandwagon left after we lost two
games in a row
and there was the obstruction call he
took off and die hard bill
[ __ ] hung around all right anyways
first he says i just want to say love
the podcast and your comedy specials
well thank you very much uh he goes my
question
do you think 29 is too old just to start
doing stand-up
um i have a decent full-time job as a
paralegal and consider myself lucky to
be gainfully employed however life in an
office is miserable and it gets worse as
the years pile on i'm not quitting
anytime soon but i've thought about
starting to try open mics to see if i'm
any good and maybe
[Music]
and maybe what maybe help me be a little
more outgoing what do you think is it
still possible when you're damn near
30 thanks and go [ __ ] yourself dude
abso-fucking-lutely
absolutely
and this is the thing yeah don't quit
your day job
that's what i did i i had a day job
and i was like let me try this stand-up
thing and i started doing it and i
immediately loved it and i just kept
working on it and working on it working
on it but i didn't leave my day job
until um
i actually kept my day job when i could
have left it i was making enough money
where i could live but i kept my day job
because i knew i was moving down to new
york
and i wanted to save up some money so i
could
um
because i knew that i i you know i
wasn't going to show up in new york and
oh great this [ __ ] guy we don't know
is here let's give him a bunch of stage
time i knew i was going to have to
struggle
so i would absolutely 100 percent
if you're thinking about trying it
definitely try even if you just do it
one time you did it
you did it i went skydiving one time
ever tell you guys that story i went
skydiving one time i did a static line
jump in pepperell massachusetts back in
the day
and uh
i almost had a problem
they said sit in the door sit in the
door get out go
so you sit in the door they open the
door to the plane you sit in the door
and then when they say get out you put
your feet you put one foot your left
foot
on this almost looks like an engine
mount that's above one of the wheels of
this [ __ ] plane
and then you're hanging on
to the support for the wing that is
above the [ __ ] plane you're basically
like a goddamn wing walker
and then
it'd be basically if you if you leaned
up against the bar if you put your body
at a 45 degree angle and you leaned up
against the bar
in the upright push-up position and then
you went down like you were coming down
to the floor that's basically the
position you're in like you're down to
the floor except it's the support to the
wing and then you have one foot on the
engine what looks like an engine mount
and then you have another foot pointed
straight out behind you
because what you're gonna do it says get
you know sit the door get out and go
when he slaps your shoulder you let go
of the [ __ ] plane which makes no
[ __ ] sense
and then you bring that other leg up
parallel to where your other one was
sitting out and then you arc
all right and what i did was a static
line jump so i don't have to pull the
chute but i don't have anybody with me
it's a static line jump and as you let
go it pulls your chute and you and you
go arc one thousand two one thousand
three one thousand look if nothing look
reach pull i still remember that [ __ ]
like it was yesterday
two one thousand three one thousand and
it's look you turn to see
your parachute
to see if it's opened if it's open
properly properly but look if nothing
look you look down to where your reserve
is because if you don't
look where it is for some reason you
might not be able to grab it so look if
nothing look reach pull and then you
pull your reserve shoot and hopefully
that thing [ __ ] opens or you're gonna
bounce
so
he's he was going to sit in the door and
i was like what he's going sit in the
door i thought he said close the door
he's going sit and i thought okay so sit
in the door so i sit in the door
and
then he goes get out i got out and then
he said go
and when i let go i didn't arc
i tried to grab for something and i
started doing front flips as my shoot
was coming out and i felt
it going by the inside of my right leg i
felt this something
touched my right thigh and i was going
oh my god i'm gonna get i'm gonna get
wound up in this [ __ ] thing and uh i
don't know who packed that shoot but
thank god it [ __ ] came out
and then you had like a little
transistor radio or some [ __ ] on your
shoulder
and then they just talked you down
you know right toggle left toggle you
had to pull it all the way down to your
knee and i remember there was this fat
chick in the class and she couldn't get
it around her ass and she ended up
landing across the street in a pile of
loom and she dislocated her knee uh
fortunately that did not happen for me
and it was uh it was pretty awesome but
i did it that one time never needed to
do it again and uh i have the story i
have the experience so maybe stand-up
will just be that for you
um or
you could
have the experience that i had where the
first time i walked to the microphone i
felt like i was like an out-of-body
experience like i was watching myself do
it
and
it was
i found my calling in life which is
probably
one of the most exciting things other
than finding the person you're supposed
to be with in life
so
i gotta tell you this dude if you're in
your office every day and it
and it is a miserable thing
that could mean that you're not you
don't have the right job or you need
some sort of outlet maybe you're working
too hard and maybe just going out and
doing this one night
and kind of remembering to try
that going out and trying new things
is a fun thing to do
that you don't have to just be a hundred
percent about your career that's i think
that's something a lot of [ __ ] adults
forget to do
after a while and you have like that
thing once you get your life down
you know
i get up at this hour i drive down this
street i go to work i do the same thing
every day i'm comfortable i know
everybody there's no new challenges
and then no one's gonna make fun of me
like they did on the playground and
punch me in the face for having freckles
right you can really get caught in that
and then you get in a rut so i don't
know if you're just in a rut with work
or whatever
but i would definitely recommend trying
uh
going out and trying to stand up believe
me dude
that's uh i'm having more fun with it
than i ever had and i'm 22 years in and
i've i never feel like uh well i've had
some struggles you know but
you do with anything but
when i'm on stage doing it i never feel
like
um
i don't feel like how you feel in the
office but i'm not gonna lie to you
before i started selling tickets you
would when you was just a [ __ ] awful
show
and there was no security and everything
but you know anything worth
having
you know it was [ __ ] easy everybody
would do it so anyways i'm getting too
long-winded here go out and try all
right
next one
uh dear bill
you ruined the hobbit
um he said i'm a big fan of the podcast
and your comedy unfortunately i made the
mistake of looking up your comedy on
youtube and came across the
clip where you took a [ __ ] on lord of
the rings
you know what's funny i don't even
remember doing half of this [ __ ]
he said it was the scene where the
gandalf
stumbles
summons shadow facts
the lord of all horses oh jesus and you
pointed out
how ridiculous that was
oh i remember that i am the lord of all
horses it's just so [ __ ] over the top
he goes i don't consider myself to be a
big nerd but i do love star wars lord of
the rings and all that nerd stuff i like
all of that [ __ ] i watched the hobbit
for the first time yesterday and every
time they said something ridiculous i
pictured your ginger mug going oh geez
i was literally laughing every 30
seconds well there you go then i turned
lord of the rings into a comedy for you
um
you know i saw a clip of one of those
things where the guy just looks like a
and he has elf ears
and he talks to the the to the i'm
assuming a wizard
you know why don't wizards ever get a
haircut
you know why don't they ever have a sh
take you know take a shave why don't you
know why
why can't you be a clean-cut wizard are
you so busy moving [ __ ] mountains
you know somebody get you know
get them with one of those little
toiletry bags
the straight razor
um i was watching one of those things
and
i remember where the [ __ ] i was at
so i on a plane was i watching tv it's
all running together at this point my
age days fly by so quick you can't even
remember did i dream that
or did my neighbor say it i can't even
[ __ ] remember but i was watching one
of those
elf movies
and uh
the [ __ ] lead dude
with the karl malden nose and the spock
ears
he he found he found a ring
now for some reason i thought the ring
the lord of the rings like if you had
the rings i thought the rings were like
you know those magic rings that hacky
magicians pull apart i thought that they
were that big it looked like you found a
wedding ring
i don't [ __ ] know anyways
so he said he was laughing every 30
seconds whatever am i he said i hope
you're happy that my enjoyment of the
hobbit
was a casualty on your war on nerds i
don't have a war on nerds i just call
them out on their [ __ ]
how arrogant is that i just try to keep
them honest
i do think that they should teach nerds
how to fight rather than trying to stop
bullying because you're not going to end
bullying
you know it's like i started watching
the uh
the ultimate fighter
where they have these the women fighters
now and i'm telling when i watch
when i watch those women fight i get
like
like psyched for
going like i hope some pervert tries to
grab her ass
like i hope a rapist like i would never
wish that on any of them but for the
love of god the next time a rapist tries
to rape a woman a woman a woman
like if she has the [ __ ] skills that
the women on the on
the ultimate fighter i mean it's just
going to be
it's just going to be a great day for
for humanity
um
you got to see that show dude these
these women like for the most part they
they spar with men because i don't think
there's enough women in the sport or
whatever so these guys are kind of
half-assing it and the women are going
like it's you know it's okay to hit me
in the face
i'm just sitting there like watching the
guy fighter still pulling his punches it
just goes against everything
that you were taught and everything that
is just right in the world
to ball your fist up and actually swing
and and punch a woman is just like
i just don't think christmas would ever
be the same after that like it just it
would just be something
you just you just would lose something
um but anyways i mean they they like
i can tell you without a doubt
every woman on that show would beat the
living [ __ ] out of me i wouldn't have a
prayer
there's nothing you can do once that
mixed martial arts you know if a woman
look like a woman boxer you have a
chance you can out wear and you can just
[ __ ] just
shoot her legs and [ __ ] put her on
her back and just smother her with a
pillow from the couch right you got a
shot but that ufc [ __ ] you take him to
the ground and then what then they're
gonna [ __ ] put you in an arm bar
they're gonna choke you out it's gonna
be over
so of course me being a guy
being a [ __ ] pig i i of course got to
look at him in a sexual way and i'm like
going like all right
how do you rock that girl's world
in the [ __ ] bedroom and i don't mean
the girly ones i mean the [ __ ] ones
that are like the one who the one who's
a champion
the the heavyweight champion or whatever
like i don't know what what her name is
but that one i was just sitting there
going all right
what would she like in bed
that's gonna go she is gonna go one way
or the other
she is either exactly
what you think she is
you know
like the [ __ ] chicago bears they're
exactly we thought they were we let him
off the hook
she's easy exactly what you think she's
gonna be what she's gonna be dominant
and [ __ ] holding you down
slash scaring the [ __ ] out of you
wondering if she's gonna rip your dick
off or
i i would actually bet
i don't know
if you went the other way
that she would actually be submissive
she'd be so sick of beating the [ __ ] out
of guys
down in the octagon that she would
actually almost like one of those
[ __ ] uh
wall street guys
that's calling all the shots and then
it's just gets so [ __ ] sick of
dominating the the entire [ __ ] planet
that late at night goes to one of those
s m things and gets on a swing with one
of those orange balls in his mouth
i don't [ __ ] know but that's the [ __ ]
i think of when i watch that show you
should definitely watch the ultimate
fighter uh
dude they had this woman she looked like
a [ __ ] librarian
or you know this nerd she lost
but i just thought it was [ __ ]
awesome just looking at her going like
look at that woman you would have no
clue you'd have no clue that you know
if you talk some [ __ ] to her that she
would just start raining elbows down on
you i just think it's i think it's
amazing it's really [ __ ] amazing
anyways let's let's get on with the uh
so i guess i ruined the podcast for this
guy i got to read the last paragraph
here
he says uh also it might it might be a
good idea to watch the movie and record
your reactions
oh dude i can't sit through that [ __ ]
like it's too [ __ ] long he goes
there's a scene where a wizard called
radagast
radagast the brown is being chased by
wargs
big wolves riding a sleigh pulled by
bunny rabbits
dude this movie like
i would i i would think that
more like uh people who were into like
hallucinogens would actually watch this
movie because that actually sounds
[ __ ] pretty amazing he says gandalf
goes
you can't outrun these wargs
they are vermilion works
the other wizard actually responds
there are
all these are and then he says in
parentheses some corny fantasy place
rabbits i'd like to see them try
oh so he goes you can't outrun the the
war these wars they're vermilion wargs
and he said well these are lilliputian
rabbits i'd like to see them try that's
actual [ __ ] dialogue
he goes and then they actually zoom in
on his face with a look of pseudo pseudo
badass determination you know what dude
i think i'm gonna watch that movie
i think i i'll eat up like a [ __ ] pot
cookie maybe i'll watch i don't want to
do that though i don't want to put that
on youtube me [ __ ] high
giggling like a [ __ ] school girl
watching some wizard on a [ __ ] rabbit
i don't want to do that
publicly i don't want to do that
publicly all right carrie underwood
i said she's a singer right
he said i recently listened to your
podcast
or is that one of those guys with a
woman name
you know like that shimar guy whatever
the [ __ ] his name is
does the hair products
and also acts in movies doesn't he
i can't was [ __ ] amos he goes i
recently listened to your podcast
concerning the song before he cheats by
carrie underwood very funny by the way
uh you might be interested to know how
she has a new song
she has a new song out that takes that
theme to a completely new level in the
song
two black cadillacs a woman discovers
her husband is cheating on her
apparently the mistress didn't realize
he was married because she and the wife
collaborate on murdering the guy
uh not just destroying his truck and
humiliating him in front of a new girl
they end the guy's life here are a few
lines from the end of the song
all right it says yeah they they took
turns
laying a rose down
threw a handful of dirt deep into the
ground
he's not the only one
who had a secret to hide so i'm thinking
about writing my own country song the
title might be something like
cold dinner raw knuckles
[Music]
yeah well you know
that's one of those double standards
that you understand why it exists
you know it's not like women go around
killing guys all the [ __ ] time when
it really comes to violence guys do it
more to women than the other way around
and uh
it's one of the things that makes it
being a guy funny
because if a woman actually like right
to the point of like cutting getting
your dick cut off by a woman like it's
just considered funny like well do she
cut your dick off like other guys just
think it's hilarious we're not gonna
wear pink
you know for all the guys who got their
dicks
[ __ ] sliced off and thrown in a
garbage disposal well not we're just
gonna laugh at you
um
whatever you know what i really hear
that i really don't hear that as an
anti-man thing i hear somebody who's
struggling to find a follow-up hit and
is going back to the well possibly one
too many times but then again i listened
to ac dc and they had like three or four
themes that they
have been doing for 40 years and i think
they sound better better than ever
right they sing about their balls the
devil
women
and electricity
and it's worked for them
so good for her good for her
uh maybe next one will be like uh the
guy comes back like a zombie
and she has a relationship with a zombie
and then he cheats on her
and then i don't know what she does
however you kill a [ __ ] zombie i'd
have to watch lord of the rings to
figure that one out um advice on having
a baby she had a baby man she had a baby
advice on having a baby hey bill i need
some advice
you're talking to me i what the [ __ ]
i'm nowhere near that he said my wife
and i are both 27 years old she's a
graduate from college and working i'm
getting a master's degree and will not
be done for another two and a half years
the issue is she is getting to the point
where she wants to have a baby not now
but some
but sometime right after i graduate i on
the other hand am not wanting
a baby anytime soon but
no but by the time i graduate i will
have been in college for nearly eight
years
after i graduate my wife and i will have
a dual income of well over a hundred
grand a year i grew up in a family in a
fairly poor family i worked hard to get
my schooling so i want to enjoy the
rewards i want a nice apartment nice
things
and to travel the world if we just start
having kids we won't be able to travel
and if we
just have kids right after i graduate
i'll go from a life of stress from
school to a life of stress from
parenthood but i understand my wife's
concern
if we wait until we are 33 or 34 to
start having kids we could have some
trouble conceiving and if it takes
us too long she could give birth to a
mentally challenged child which
does run in my family jesus christ dude
this is one of the more serious ones i
love my wife and plan on being with her
the rest of my life it's just a shame
that my goals are to travel and have
nice things and her goals are to start a
family so what do you think bill any
advice uh that's some pretty heavy [ __ ]
there um
well i don't understand why when you're
you're
um
going to school right now that you guys
can't
save up a little bit of money and go to
aruba for a few days you can do little
mini once
you know what i mean
i think there's a way to kind of do both
and um i think if you express all your
concerns to your wife
and just say look i don't want to be
that couple that just goes from school
to having kids and then once we have
kids all we do is just
do the kid thing um
i don't know dude
i don't know what to tell you here um
[ __ ]
i i definitely understand i mean you
went from a life of poverty it's right
to a life of school and then you're
going to go right to a life of being a
parent when do you actually get to sit
back
and enjoy a nice flat screen tv watching
some sports or maybe go
travel in europe or something like that
um
look dude you could do this you could
have a kid
i don't know how close you are with you
know the parents on either side
um i think you can have your cake and
eat it why don't you just have a [ __ ]
kid and then also save up for a [ __ ]
epic 10-day trip somewhere
through um
through europe and then just just make a
pact with your wife and just say listen
once every two years
or once every whatever
i want to uh i want to go on a trip and
we'll leave the kid behind or the kids
behind
my parents did that they went to vegas
and my grand parents came to town it was
great we ended up developing a
relationship with our grandparents it
was a good thing and it was also good
socially
it was good for us as kids to have a
different sort of disciplinary dynamic
jesus christ i remember i tested my
grandmother too when she broke a [ __ ]
wooden spoon would have been over my
head but i got my arm up and i blocked
it
i kept messing i saw her
the way we were renting this
we weren't
lived in a duplex when i was a kid for a
certain uh number of years and um
the way we had it set up
was uh
it went kitchen living room and then
dining room so you had to walk through
the living room we kind of altered the
living room and kitchen a couple of
times trying to figure out which was
best
and uh this was just a period where
there was uh it went kitchen and then we
had the living room and then we were
using
the other room as a dining room so
anyways there was this old shitty rug
and there was a hole in it so my mother
had put a throw rug over the hole on the
floor so i saw my grandmother walk by
through the living room as she was
setting the table and she saw
the uh the throw rug was messed up and i
just heard her mumble to herself she
said now why did this keep getting
messed up
so
she walked into the kitchen that was
literally my cue she'd straighten it out
walk to the kitchen so i said all right
[ __ ] so i got off the couch and i messed
it up and went over i went back and i
sat down
so then she comes walking out with the
dishes or the food and she sees it again
she goes now what just happened it was
just straighten this out so she
straightens it out goes in the dining
room walks back into the kitchen and i
got up and i messed it up again she came
third time sees it again
and she doesn't [ __ ] say anything
which should have been a warning to me
so she straightened it out and then she
walked into the kitchen
and turned the corner
and i got back up again to go mess it up
and right as i'm grabbing it to mess it
up i hear i hear this stomp and she took
a quick step back and looked back out
right in the middle of it saw me messing
it up and she just had this wooden spoon
in her hand and just came [ __ ] flying
at me
like if it was an axe i wouldn't be here
right it was a hatchet i would have been
dead she gave me like billy bob when she
[ __ ] when he kills that country
singer right came flying at me i just
remember crouching down and putting my
arm up
and it it [ __ ] snapped in half over
my forearm
she had this look of anger on her face
slammed it down snapped it over my arm
and then she just
after it snapped she just went
well that's the end of that spoon and
then she just walked back out into the
kitchen
and that was it so i think that's a good
thing if they
if they stay with their grandparents i
think you can do both i think as a
couple if you really sit down and you
say what's important to you um
you know and this is very easy for me to
say not having
a child
and having it completely consume your
life who knows your priorities might
change
or whatever but there's also something
to say too that if you start early
i mean if you started now you're 27 your
kid would be 18 when you're 45 my age
right now and then you can travel
um you know 45 kids out of college by
the time you're 49 then you have your
golden years 50s 60s 70s 80s depending
on how if you eat right you juice
you can live right up to [ __ ] 90 and
you can go see the goddamn world but
there's no reason why you can't do that
right now
even though that you're in school
there's no reason why you can't go to
puerto rico or go to hawaii
there's some beautiful cities up in
canada you know
vancouver toronto montreal is [ __ ]
tremendous
um
there's all beautiful uh cities here in
the states there's all kinds of things
that you can do and you can do them
really cheaply when you don't have any
kids
dude literally just backpack it just put
a backpack on stay in [ __ ] hostels
who gives a [ __ ]
you know
just go i would just say go and do it i
would just
yeah do it now do it now
uh but i think you can do both and um i
also say everybody i know who's ever had
a kid has never regretted it never never
ever regretted it so um
you know i i but i think it's also
important that if you do something like
that to to to not lose yourself in all
of it all right there i've said my piece
all right continuing on here alcohol
problem
hey bill love the podcast watching you
stand up right now on netflix and has me
crying left thank you thank you thank
you anyways i'm 25 i'm a 25 year old
male and i'm starting to come to terms
with the fact i have an alcohol oh wait
i forgot to do the other part uh
advertising here hang on sorry
ah [ __ ] i always forget the other ones
all right e-voice e-voice everybody if
you're an entrepreneur and a customer
calls do you want to you do you want it
to seem like you're in a high-rise
window view fancy pants office or do you
want them to know that you're sitting
there in your underwears
with e-voice you can create the
appearance of an entire building
sales customer service tech support you
name it it's going to seem like you're
sitting in a high-rise give your
customers the royal treatment with
e-voice e-voice will forward business
calls to your home mobile or any number
you choose wherever you are e-voice will
find you you don't have time to take a
call no big deal it's routed directly to
your voicemail and you can read it
um at your convenience as an email
e-voice not only gives you an edge over
your competitors it takes away the edge
the big companies have over you right
now and now you can try e-voice for free
for 30 days go to evoice.com or just go
to the podcast page at billboard.com and
click on the e-voice banner and last but
not least stamps.com everybody
the post office version of dollar shave
club this makes your life easier when
was the last time you heard of a post
office being open 24 7. huh never they
usually have limited hours could be
closed when you get there that's why you
need stamps.com gets postage you can get
postage when it's convenient for you
you're in the driver's seat you can get
it 24 7 right from your own desk
stamps.com will save you time and the
hassle of going to the post office no
more driving finding parking standing in
the lines all of that crap just use your
own computer and your printer to get
official us postage for any letter or
package and the mailman picks it up
can't be any easier you'll save money
with stamps.com too get exact postage
the intense the instant you need it no
more overpaying even get a special
postage discounts uh that you can't get
at the post office i use dance.com to
send out my posters my dvds my t-shirts
whatever crap i'm selling i've never had
a problem and i'm a [ __ ] so if i can do
it you can do it too so right now use my
last name bur burr for this special
offer no risk trial plus 110 bonus offer
that includes a digital scale and up to
55 dollars free postage don't wait go to
stamps.com before you do anything else
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page and type in bur burr that
stamps.com enter bur all right
alcohol problem
hey bill i love the podcast
anyways i am 25 year old male and i'm
starting to come to terms with the fact
i have an alcohol problem i drink six
days a week and black out at least once
a week
all right well
the only saving grace you have is your
25 so
you might just be a little immature i
don't know if you're an actual alcoholic
but let me read the rest of this
says i drink six days a week blank at
least once the nights i get really drunk
i really regret doing it and regret my
actions nothing serious just phone or
text conversations i have with people
i've considered going to aaa but never
have gone through with it um i finally
quit smoking two months ago and i'm
worried if i try to quit drinking now i
will start going crazy i know you have
always mentioned you are stupid but i
honestly agree with most of the advice
you give up well thank you he said my
question is do you think i should try
and quit cold turkey
or are there any other options i can
take one of my concerns with quitting
completely is that most of my friends
drink and go out on weekends
um and i don't want to list risk losing
all of my social life and seeing
and
seeing me friends
i got all irish there and seeing me
friends appreciate the advice
um
all right dude all i can do is just tell
you what has worked for me when i'm not
drinking and
um
the first two three days are brutal
because all you've gone is two three
days and there's definitely that feeling
of well if i drink now i can start over
again just trying to make up three days
but if you can get through the first two
three days once you get to the fourth
day
it's like all right i got a nice little
streak going here like i'm up to six
days right now
and um
one of the hardest things to do is when
you go out socially with people
but i found that all you have to do all
i have to do because i don't know how
dude if you're a full-on alcoholic and
you have the disease it might be
harder for you and you really should
probably
i would say talk to a recovered
alcoholic
but if you're like me
all it takes is going out to the bar
that first time when everybody's
drinking
and you just order a uh i try to stay
away from soda and club soda because
then i mean that shit's not good for
either and i usually just order the
cranberry juice and deal with the
departed well what are you in your
period jokes that everybody does i
usually just go i don't even do
cranberry and soda i just do cranberry
juice straight up with a lime
and i just sort of nurse that
and then
i just kind of drink waters and
you're actually it's you [ __ ] you just
got to do that that one night and then
you've kind of set up
a new social experience that you're
comfortable with and you can still go
out
and i gotta tell you you get a distinct
advantage when you're sober and
everybody else is basically getting
[ __ ] up because
they're kind of
first of all it's really entertaining to
watch people just sort of roof roofie
themselves
and you get through watching their
behavior you get to see all the dumb
things that you've done
um so you get to um
without judging your friends you just
sort of get to be like wow i was doing
that i was doing that
especially with alcohol i always say
judgment's the first thing to go
and um
i don't know i think you also have a
better chance of meeting um
a really nice woman if you're the sober
one because you're going to come off as
responsible and also if your friends are
also hitting on her and they're all
sloppy drunk
you're gonna look even better yourself
so i would
you know if you if you're not feeling a
a which i understand if
just try uh
you what it is i i don't know i have to
replace the activity
like
this week i decided
you know that i was gonna stop drinking
so then what i did was i dove into
playing drums
and i'm doing that that mike johnston
10 days to faster hands workout so i
just sort of
replace
you know
like at night i just sort of like okay
i'll go downstairs and i'll work on i'll
do the practice pad thing
and
uh you know i started working out
he just
you know what it is dude
i f you got to replace
the time that you're drinking and doing
dumb [ __ ] with [ __ ] that's also fun but
you're sober doing it because
for me it's like if i just don't drink
and i'm just sitting around doing
nothing that's going to make me want to
drink because it's just like well i
usually go out and drink and have fun
right now
but if i'm actually doing something else
um like went out and i saw a movie last
night
you just you fill up the time dude learn
how to cook
there's all kinds of you learn a [ __ ]
second language there's all kinds of
things dude that like you know basically
you're in your 20s right now
and uh you know you're trying to appeal
to the opposite sex here so you know if
you can add some [ __ ] to your game
you're going to move up in the draft
you're going to get a better woman here
if you're [ __ ] bilingual what woman
doesn't like that you're sober and
responsible she's going to like that who
knows you learn to play a couple of
songs on a flamenco guitar you take
around on a [ __ ] rowboat you're in
there
a bunch of grit nothing bad comes from
becoming sober other than you you are
bored shitless but you you your head
gets smaller because you drop all that
booze weight i'm telling you you won't
regret it you definitely won't regret it
um
but like i said if you got the disease
in that thing you might you're going to
need more professional help and i would
actually seek out a fellow
alcoholic
um
and then i would use a a and all of that
[ __ ] you you know
i don't know i'm just a control freak
and i don't like people telling me what
to do so i would have to use it in a way
that worked for me
you know i'm not gonna be standing down
there smoking cigarettes eating donuts
you know talking those people with their
yellow fingers and [ __ ]
like i couldn't do it that way i got
buddies of mine they they go every once
in a while i go to a meeting
you know
like the way i go to church every once
in a while [ __ ] once a year they'll
do it but whatever works for you but
nothing bad ever comes from uh
cleaning up your act so uh
i i hope that helps you all right okay
that's the podcast for this week
everybody
um
i'm off the road again this week i'm
definitely going to be around um
work i might have a surprise show out
here in l.a where i'm actually going to
be you know working on my act
possibly next week i think there's
rumors that i might be doing a full hour
at a local comedy club and um because i
gotta make sure i'm on my game when i do
uh dc new york and upper dobby
um that's it that's a podcast everybody
i hope you enjoyed it uh here's the wrap
up now that the show's over don't forget
once again to sign up for your free
trial of hulu plus uh hulu plus lets you
binge on thousands of hit shows anytime
anywhere on your tv pc smartphone or
tablet
uh it's the future it's the way to watch
tv
in the future right now okay support
this podcast
podcast podcast and get an extended free
trial of hulu plus when you go to the
podcast page at billboard.com and click
the hulu plus banner or go to
huluplus.com
bill that's huluplus.com bill that is
the podcast for this week once again
i'll be down lago on la cienega just
north of beverly boulevard
and uh i'm going to be doing this great
benefit
i love doing benefits because i'm a
piece of [ __ ] god knows i need to work
on my karma lord knows that so i get to
go down and help a wonderful cause that
helps out uh
you know come on helps out pit bulls
what's better than a dog isn't that
right cleo cleo come over here come here
cleo
she's sleeping
cleodio
hey
now she's out like a light
um i'm boring her with my podcast all
right that's it all right everybody go
[ __ ] yourselves i'll talk to you next
week and uh if you haven't watched the
world series yet uh said dandy two games
a piece one more game in st louis oh you
know what i didn't talk about
i know that the the world series has
always been two three two
i always feel like
i always just feel like the three in the
middle what would you rather have
if you were managing the team
would you rather i just feel like the
advantage goes to the team with the
lesser record with those three in the
middle even though overall
four out of seven games
you're gonna be on the road
i just feel like the way it's broken up
you just sort of spend a weekend in
boston and then you host a home stand
right
you got three straight games you can
sleep in your own bed eat your own food
[ __ ] chill out and then if need be
you go back and you you deal with
another weekend they break it up nicely
um
and i feel like the two three two it
just gives the team with the lesser
record home field advantage to the first
five games it makes games one and two a
must win for the team with the better
record
but uh i don't know maybe that's just me
my anxiety as a fan and maybe
professional athletes could they don't
give a [ __ ]
but i've always found that weird
like i i liked when the nba used to do
two two one one one um
it seemed fairer but i think the
athletes didn't like the travel you know
and they got to lug all that tv
equipment i don't know
just that's just one to think about all
right so that's the deal everybody
that's the podcast for this week go [ __ ]
yourselves
[Music]
[Applause]
i think about it
again if i could
[Music]
all night
the vacant notion of the city lights
the vacuum faces
[Music]
is
and that is nothing new
[Music]
you